this is jocko podcast number 306 with
echo charles and me jocko willing good
evening echo good evening and also
joining us again tonight dave burke good
evening dave good evening
so uh
i said this book was going to take a
while i actually said that to you a year
ago that when we do this book it's going
to take a while
but we are going to continue our review
of the book on
the psychology of military incompetence
which we started on podcast 303 303 304
305 here we are on 306 and there's gonna
be more
so if you haven't listened to three or
three three or four three or five go
back listen to those and if you have
less than those then what you heard on
those was basically the setup
it was the setup it was the background
information
that we have been that we need to get
into the actual theories of how
psychology plays a role in military
incompetence
and with that let's let's get back to
the book so this this this part of the
book is called part two and this is
where we're no longer covering
historical
incidents or battles
although the reason i had to read them
all was because he does refer back to
him quite a bit and i will say as i went
through the as i was kind of navigating
how to do this
i'm not going back as much as he is so
when he goes back i might not cover
every single one he goes back a little
bit more
but
so this part of the book is
what's
what he's actually trying to figure out
how does how does psychology play a role
in incompetence so here we go chapter 13
is there a case to answer
he says that now that we have completed
a survey of survey covering 100 years of
military mishaps what conclusions can be
drawn regarding the incidence
of military incompetence there are a
number of possible answers firstly it
could be argued that so-called
incompetence and high levels of command
is really a figment of the imagination
of vindictive inaccurate or untruthful
historians
so
that's one conclusion a second
conclusion might be what seems to have
been military incompetence was really
due to other non-military factors such
as governmental stinginess
vagaries of the weather and sheer bad
luck
a third conclusion might be that since
every military action is an uncontrolled
experiment in the sense that it can
never be known what would have been the
outcome had been had decisions been
different there remains an almost
unimaginable possibility that things
might have been worse
that what was done did represent the
least disastrous
of possible courses open
so there are some different reasons why
you could say well you know it's not
really military incompetence it's just
that historians are jerks
it's just that there's
factors that no one can control
and that actually these decisions that
were made were good but you know it's
just a bad situation so these are the
best things that could happen
his response to that is no one would
deny there's more to grain of truth and
all these propositions cool
facts do get distorted and the telling
disasters are indeed more newsworthy
than successes
writers undoubtedly do enjoy painting
the worst possible picture of their
particular
bet noirs
many generals have had to contend with
ineptitude
uninformed interference and the
stinginess of their political masters
and of course things could have been
worse
there are
counter arguments however because they
are
surrogate father figures people are only
too ready and anxious to love their
admirals and generals particularly in a
time of war we see that a lot right
like if someone was in the military
then they must be awesome
and in recent years that's gotten
i would say even more prolific if
someone's a vet then anything they say
has some merit and value and then you
figure if they're a vet whatever they
say has merit and value if they were an
admiral or they were a general then they
must just be awesome they just must be
speaking the truth
which we know not to be
true i'm gonna fast forward a little bit
under the circumstances this book takes
the view that certain sorts of
incompetence have been an enduring
feature of the military scene and that
amongst the millions of officers and men
who have fought heroically and
efficiently often under the most trying
conditions there have marched a small
but influential number whose ability has
fallen far short of that required by the
positions which they held so again he
likes to point this out from time to
time and this is one of those times that
this isn't about every military officer
and i'm not making this about every
military officer i worked for awesome
military officers dave
yeah at every level there are great
military officers every level every
service there's great military officers
but it is interesting he says a small
but influential number
so these are people that are totally
inept at being military leaders and yet
they end up in really powerful positions
he says two questions that then occur is
there any common pattern to this
incompetence and
if there is whence does it arise
as a first step towards answering these
questions let us try and summarize the
data contained in the foregoing chapters
in brief then
military incompetence involves
[Music]
one
a serious wastage of human resources and
failures to observe one of the first
principles of war economy of force
[Music]
this failure derives in part from an
inability to make war swiftly it also
derives from certain attitudes of mind
which we shall consider presently so
that's the number one thing that's
showing that someone's an inept leader
is when they have
massive wastage of human life
number two a fundamental conservatism
and clinging to outworn tradition an
inability to profit from past experience
owing in part to a refusal to admit past
mistakes g
do we even have to go any deeper on that
one or is everyone just immediately
understanding what's going on with that
if you can't admit your past mistakes if
you can't take ownership of your
mistakes you don't make any improvement
it also involves a failure to use or
tendency to misuse available technology
this one's a massive
profit from past experience
failure to profit from past experience
you don't learn anything number three a
tendency to reject or ignore information
which is unpalatable
or which conflicts with preconceptions
number four a tendency to underestimate
the enemy and overestimate the
capabilities of one's own side
indecisiveness number five
indecisiveness and a tendency to
abdicate from the role of decision maker
number six an obstinate persistence in a
given task
despite strong contrary evidence
obstinate persistence in a given task
that's when you are this is uh
i don't know if you guys have anything
like this dave but
when you're parachuting
what one of the ways that people die
when parachuting is they have a problem
with their main parachute
and they just keep trying to fix that
problem and they get target fixation and
they just they just and they never go to
the reserve they never go to the reserve
yeah
can that happen in the cockpit yeah
absolutely and
maybe a slightly different different
version of that is you can have a system
that is a you know it's a critical
system that you need
but it wouldn't be the difference
between
returning home safely and not but you'll
you'll spend so much time trying to
resolve the problem that system is
causing that it can lead you to focusing
on that so much that you stop paying
attention to other things and it'll lead
you to a mishap when even though it
could be a pro a real problem it should
never lead you down the path of of
crashing or losing the airplane
and
what you really need to do is
ignores probably the wrong word but if
you can't solve this move move on to
something else and get the airplane back
safely and they'll spit people will
devote 100 of their attention to that
all the way to the point that they
crashed the airplane as a result of it
when it would not have caused a crash
it's kind of crazy
and that human element of
the fixation i think is the word you use
the fixation on that you know i was just
talking about this at the muster we are
genetically programmed to to fixate yes
because if you're a caveman and you
can't concentrate on the tiger that's
you know prowling up on you and you're
distracted by other things then you're
gonna die right so we're programmed to
focus on what's right in front of us
that's why people so often lose
strategic vision and they can't detach
and they don't see what else is
happening that's that's why you get
flanked that's why you keep trying to
fix your parachute until you hit the
dirt or while you concentrate on some
instrument panel
until you run out of fuel or you run
into a mountain exactly
what's the term when someone
hits a mountain with no like no brakes
or whatever yeah
we call it sea fit controlled flight
into terrain
which means you're fully in control of
the aircraft as you do it as you hit
that mountain
because you are so fixated on something
else
you know it's not like hey i'm tumbling
out of the sky i'm trying to save this
airplane i hit the ground it's like hey
i'm flying perfectly
normal flying i might be i'm [__] i'm
fixated on or focusing on something
that's a problem but i'm going to fully
control level flight into the ground or
into the mountain that is totally
avoidable had it not been for that
fixation
it's as far as mishaps go it's common
it's not uncommon well the the first
time i i remember hearing that was when
kobe bryant's helicopter crashed and i
think that was because they couldn't see
right they they couldn't see but there
was nothing wrong with the helicopter
all they were just flying and he
obviously i think they were in a fog and
so got disoriented and just flew just
full speed no factor into the into the
mountain yeah and like the worst
versions of that is
um
they're all terrible is i'm i'm in a
dive like i'm going to do a 45 degree
dive i'm diving down towards the target
which is what you're supposed to do
you're going to get into it outside and
you're going to dive down towards the
target to help uh refine where you're
going to drop the bomb and i'm going to
focus on the display that makes sure
that my
targeting my reticle the the aiming
point is exactly where i wanted a little
adjustment to keep i'll keep adjusting
that targeting point to be exact where i
want it and i'll go through my minimum
altitudes and i will fly straight into
the ground all the while just
focusing on that targeting point and
i'll never try to pull up i'll never try
to recover i'll ignore warnings that say
your altitude's getting low and
pilots will fly directly into the ground
working on something else and a
perfectly safe effective flying area
with no problems at all that is
literally the exact same thing that
happens a guy skydiving well it's a
little bit different because with the
guys skydiving they're trying to fix a
problem usually i'm so i suppose there
are some cases you know this is why
again referring back to the monster i
was talking about the the leadership
loop and yeah the the main bullet at the
bottom both for the ooda loop and the
leadership loop is you can't get stuck
you can't get stuck focused on one thing
and when you do get focused on one thing
there's just there's just
there's
the rest of the world doesn't stop right
whenever you're focused in one thing in
life the rest of the world doesn't stop
the rest of the world's going to keep
going if you don't look around it's
going to be a problem
and that's what this number is number
six an obstinate persistence in a given
task despite
strong contrary evidence that was number
six number seven a failure to exploit a
situation gained and a tendency to quote
pull punches
rather than push home an
attack number eight a failure to make
adequate reconnaissance
number nine a predilection for frontal
assaults often against the enemy's
strongest point
and again
even once again at the muster
i'm
trying to explain to people because you
know there's people that wanna that they
just wanna hear you say look someone's
called some problem just gotta go direct
that's what everybody wants to hear and
it makes
so much intuitive sense to think you
know what
i don't like dave's plan i just need to
go tell him dave i don't like your plan
and it's just
so obvious that when i say dave i don't
like your plan immediately dave is
defensive you by the way once you get
defensive you're not listening to
anything else i say and now we're not
making any progress so even though it
seems like it's the most efficient thing
to do it's not
the most efficient thing to do is say
hey dave i'm looking at your plan can
you expand on a couple of these points
because i don't think i understand them
and now his defenses are down we're
having a real conversation my mind is
actually open it's not just a little
fugazi it's real
and we're having a real conversation we
can make progress but the predilection
for the frontal assault both on the
battlefield and in a conversation with
another human being is bad and it leads
to failure
number 10 a belief in brute force rather
than the clever ruse
so there you go the jujitsu people just
cheered
a failure to make use of surprise or
deception
jiu-jitsu people just cured again
this is the kind of thing when i say
that jiu-jitsu affected my brain
these are the kind of things those three
right there
frontal assault's bad that's jiu-jitsu
uh believe in clever ruse instead of
brute force that's jiu-jitsu
make use of surprise and deception
that's jiu-jitsu
i had a buddy
i started he trained you to do i tried
jiu jitsu but he was very he was
sort of um
not training a lot and this was early
90s he trained you know some you know
and
i was like in my first month of training
jiu jitsu all the time with fabio santos
and one day this is my buddy jim
i said i i told him i came back after
like a month of training and i said hey
man here's the deal i just i just
learned this
you can't do one move a one move by
itself doesn't work because it's too
easy to defend you gotta set people up
that's what this whole thing is it's
like a trick it's a big trick
and about three days later he and i were
rolling
and he freaking
was
sinking in a choke sinking in a choke
sinking in a choke and i was like dude
this guy is not gonna be able to choke
me i know exactly boom the arm locked me
and i was like oh and he he 100
he got it he was like dude
that's what you just told me and i was
like oh my god
so
and he you know
i
he
got me
because of that thing right there
he listened to me and this guy ended up
we ended up working together a lot and
actually
just an awesome guy but anyways
he used that thing
set it up
that little that little surprise number
one it was a surprise number two it was
a ruse and number three it wasn't brute
force it was technique yeah
number 12
an undue readiness to find scapegoats
for military setbacks oh this is to use
jason gardner's uh term blame thrower
these are the people that get out the
blame thrower
ugh and the opposite of extreme
ownership right i'm just gonna find who
i'm gonna blame
a suppression number 13 a suppression or
distortion of news from the front
usually rationalized as necessary for
morale or security oh you know what that
is a really nice way of saying
a suppression or destruction of news
from the front usually rationalized as
necessary for morale or security what
we're saying here is lying to the troops
lying to the
troops and then number 14.
this one's a little strange a belief in
mystical forces
fate bad luck etc
so
there's your
there's your list of 14 things that
military incompetence involves
that's from all those historical
features those are sort of the common
themes here
fast forward a little bit on logical if
not humanitarian grounds the maintenance
of an efficient force should be the
first consideration of a military
commander other qualities of generalship
will avail him nothing if he has no one
left to do the fighting so he's focusing
on that first one saying
you should keep people alive
and this is something that um you know
sometimes people will ask us
well you got the mission and you got the
men which one's more important
and
it's very easy for me to answer that
question
the people come first because if you
don't have people you can't do any more
missions
so
yes
the mission is
absolute a top priority
but it's not the top priority you got to
take care of your people
continuing on here excessive loss of
life and high casualty figures would
therefore seem like a likely indicator
of military incompetence
known cases of what seem to be purely
administrative incompetence as for
example in what john laffin has
described as the imbecile
waltrin expedition of 1809 though the
purpose of this expedition was to attack
antwerp the troops were in fact kept in
waiting for eight weeks on unhealthy
watcherin island in zealand
in the event and owing to the
procrastination of the military
commander lord chatham
and the naval commander sir richard
strakin
7 000 men died 14 000 had their health
permanently ruined and thousands more
became ill mostly from malaria
only 217 were killed in action
so i just in case you didn't catch that
7 000
died from disease
and
um
just a disaster from an administrative
perspective but only 217 were killed in
action
while the while men were while dying men
were given no attention
and little to eat
as laughing remarks sick men were
expendable
fast forward a little bit
the second class of manpower wastage is
that involving casualties from enemy
action as a result of the incompetent
planning of senior military commanders
the men who perished in the attack on
fort ruya in the indian mutiny the
thousands of casualties from the germans
use of gas in 1915 the 13 000 who went
into captivity following the siege of
cut and 138 000 casualties of singapore
the 8 500 americans who died in the our
dens offense of 1944 and the 17 000
british american and polish who were
killed wounded or reported missing at rm
rnm
fall into this category
so he's got these i should have broken
this out earlier
he's going through the the three
different types or the different types
of how you waste
people's lives the first one is just
administrative
the second one is bad planning
and then the third one
is the third and most costly type of
manpower wastage is that resulting from
a deliberate policy of attrition adopted
by commanders who regarded soldiers as
wholly expendable generals for whom the
conservation of human life ranked lower
than in importance than various other
criteria which were governing their
actions
this is when your plan is oh a lot of
people are going to die
fast forward a little bit says in all
this we are anticipating a theory of
military incompetence rather different
from that held by proponents of the
so-called bloody fool theory
perhaps we are being too complicated
perhaps intellectual deficit could
explain the data let us then before
considering the other factors
contributing to military incompetence
first examine this older and more
favored hypothesis and so what he's
saying here is there's a lot of people
that just say oh they people make
mistakes and they make mistakes because
they're dumb
they're just dumb dumb military leaders
and that's why they make these mistakes
they're just stupid
and
well he's gonna talk about the fact that
yeah you can account for some of that
but
a lot of times you have very intelligent
leaders making really stupid decisions
and obviously his hypothesis is that's
because of their psychological nature
so here we go in chapter 14 the
intellectual ability of senior military
commanders
um te lawrence lawrence of arabia said i
feel a fundamental crippling in curious
and curiousness about our officers too
much body and too little head
so obviously he's a military guy and he
was very very smart
but he's just saying look i see a lot of
people that aren't ain't too bright too
much body too little head
what grounds are there then for the most
popular explanation of military
incompetent stupidity there's there's a
suggestion that the arms force armed
forces do not attract the best brains a
call up survey in the survey in the
united states put the status of army
officers below that of professors
physicians clergymen and school teachers
as morris janowitz remarks a liberal
ideology holds that since war is
essentially destructive the best minds
are attracted to more positive endeavors
um
it's like one of those statements you go
well you know if you're making that
statement
you would if you're a really smart
person are you thinking hey what do i
want to do do i want to go out and
build the
the next great energy platform oh do i
want to go out and kill a bunch of
people
you'd think oh well maybe the people
that are a little bit smarter are going
to lean towards building the next great
energy platform mm-hmm
that's the that's the statement anyways
yeah
what was the thing with the like the
atomic bomb where like the technology
was like
made for something
or the or the idea was like the
technology was made for something but
then you got another group of people who
are like oh that's cool technology let's
use it for this automatically you know
like for bad stuff that's what we always
think right a lot of the time where it's
like oh that's good technology yeah
who's going to weapon like someone's
going to weaponize it you know it's like
that's the fear like you put you and me
in a room
[Music]
and they're like hey we've we've created
this thing that can create a massive
amount of energy and you're you're
thinking cool we can power the world and
i'm thinking cool we can blow up our
enemies yeah exactly right
yeah
that could be
somebody's got to think that way yeah
um
it says here in training for general
trip it seems that intellectual ability
has not always counted for very much
even hague the educated soldier became
commander-in-chief of the british army
in the first world war despite a poor
academic record
this dowerlin scott this dour lowland
scott described by duff cooper as the
dunce of the family and by lord george
as utterly stupid
so you are getting some dumb people here
um fast forward a little certainly a
brilliant performance in military
schools is no guarantee of subsequent
ability general kali whose secession of
defeats culminated in 1881 in his own
demise at mujaba hill
had the distinction of passing out of
staff college with the highest
marks on record the irrelevance of early
scholarship to subsequent generalship
also finds support in napoleon and
wellington both of whom achieved very
low grades at school and in more recent
times the early academic brilliance of
lieutenant general percival
evidently availed him little at
singapore so he's given all these other
examples right you got percival who led
that total disaster in singapore who was
uh academically brilliant
napoleon and wellington who were great
generals who were junk at school and
another guy general cauley who is a
disaster on the battlefield and yet had
the highest marks on record
so
the statement is like hey
you could be really smart and do well
you could be really smart and do
horrible you could be moderately smart
and do well you could be moderately
smart and do horrible so i think the
statement here is like well
it's not
intellect is only part of it right
intellect is only part of it
what about um fighter pilots
i mean look so in the seal teams for a
while they were recruiting these
really really smart ivy league you know
harvard yale there's all this whole crew
of officers that were coming in they
were clearly
highly intellectual smart people
and they stopped recruiting those people
so heavily and the reason they stopped
recruiting those people so heavily was
two reasons one was they would do their
one platoon or two platoons and get out
and go to business school or whatever
and two was they weren't that good yeah
there was no there was no correlation
to someone that was really smart to
someone that was a really good leader on
the battlefield yeah i i think it's the
same i really do i i don't think
i don't think the personality profile
you know or even just the motivational
profile of of a lot of people in the
military is all that different certainly
when i think about seals and pilots and
as often as you and i kind of contrast
those two types of people there's a ton
of similarity there and you know the
different services in aviation have
different
sets of of requirements and you know i
think
the marine corps has the
the lowest i guess standard of academic
excellence uh in terms like what you
studied and how well you did i mean the
old joke in the marine corps was you
know if you got a 2.0 and underwater
basket weaving you could be a pilot
you know is the joke and
you know what they were saying really
was hey
you know we don't really care what you
studied now you gotta have a college
degree and i think that does demonstrate
some willingness and ability
and i'm not sure which is more important
to get through a long-term project that
hey i'm going to dedicate four years to
getting this degree that demonstrates
hey you've got some planning you've got
some interest you've got some intellect
something that's going to reveal
that you're you are have something
that's gonna be hard to do you're gonna
be willing to do that you're getting a
4.0 you know in uh you know
aerodynamics versus a 2.0 in poli-sci we
don't really care yeah that was kind of
the marine corps general approach a
little bit different for the other
services but i was kind of laughing and
kind of
thinking about this thing from a larger
standpoint of these great military
leaders that
maybe didn't have the best records
academically
i mean the two thoughts that i had is
the academics in the military aren't
that hard they're not that hard you know
what i mean like you don't need to be a
genius to get perfect scores on your
tests
um
and i think the ones that don't do that
well academically that are that still
really do well there's probably a piece
in there they're thinking like
this is dumb this is a waste of my time
what's the what's the minimum grade
requirement yeah cool i'm gonna get that
and there that actually reveals some
level of intelligence i'm not gonna
waste my time in all this stuff that i
don't really want to be doing
but i'm not gonna fail either so for for
you to sort of explain
there's some really good leaders that
didn't do so hot and then there's some
guys that just were absolutely brilliant
on paper that were terrible that is not
a stretch for me at all to picture that
in in aviation or anywhere in the middle
term like i think i know who those guys
are
yeah and really
in anything anything there's no there
i'm trying to think of a job
where the full
the where where the the the primary
thing is only intelligence
only intelligence i'm sure there's some
laboratory somewhere or some computer
programming thing where basically the
smartest person is the person that we
want in that job
but as soon as that person is in charge
of people anyone else or as soon as
there's some level of creativity or
problem solving because there's
you just you what you want is a person
that
the composite has a bunch of different
skills i mean you would think for being
a pilot
uh
there's got to be you know that that
like the spatial like when i took the
officer candidate
test and you've got to do the spatial
recognition where how far away is this
or is this aircraft or is this bird
coming to you or going away from you got
to tell from looking at it
hey obviously someone could be really
really smart and suck at that test right
not to mention eyesight not to mention
reaction time
like all those different things and then
it's the same thing with leadership you
can have someone that's super articulate
there's there's really articulate people
that aren't really that smart
i mean i served with some people like
that they're really articulate they can
put a word word together what do people
call them when eel you know that's a
skill set that like a salesperson
there's really good sales people they're
not the smartest people in the world but
they're incredible at they're incredible
conversationalists yeah right but you
wouldn't want to put them into a
situation where they've got to stand up
and talk in front of people if they
don't have that skill so just because
someone is smart that's only like one
quarter of the
of the of the math we got to do here
totally and when you're thinking about
it from a leadership standpoint
and
the recognition that that leadership
requires a whole bunch of different
things
not just being smart and taking a test
or being good at communicating it's
the recognition that it requires so many
different things none of these these
profiles that he just revealed are a big
shock to me i'm like yep yep yep those
all make sense seals pilots everyone
between and yeah
in aviation is there a couple things
that might incline you down that path
like if you can naturally get a sense if
they show you a diagram of an airplane
descending turning and slow and then you
have to match it up that some people's
brains may be oh i can't i can't see
that as well as somebody else yeah i
could see that and that's gonna account
for a small part of it that might be
good to know
but that by itself is
it's gonna
it's gonna have almost no influence in
the long-term success of this person in
his career in the military that i could
identify relatively early on of what the
spatial orientation of an airplane was
in relation to the ground do you want
that yeah that's a good idea i don't
want someone who gets confused about you
you don't want someone that's totally
lost right i mean even on that test all
you have to do is pass it right oh
that's all you have to do and then you
know if you and i were in the same thing
and i was a little bit worse i would
study it more or i figured out more or i
just after
whatever two months of looking at that
stuff we're the same yes because i
figured out how to figure it out yeah
that's right
check
um
fast forward a little bit fortunately
there are some who have seen the threat
to originality and intelligent thinking
the duke of edinburgh
felt it necessary to say finally as you
grow older try not to be afraid of new
ideas new or original ideas can be bad
as well as good but whereas an
intelligent man with an open mind can
demolish a bad idea by reasoned argument
those who allow their brains to atrophy
report resort to meaningless
catchphrases to derision and finally to
anger in the face of anything new
this is um you know this is prince
philip
duke of edinburgh recently died
i don't know if you saw his funeral but
if you have any um
any
warm place in your heart for the brits
which i certainly do
they they his his hearse was a land
rover
a military land rover that he had had
some hand in designing it was some sort
of special transport and that's what
they that's what they uh carried his
body in
but here he is this is a this is just an
incredible
thing to think about
and it's an incredible thing to be on
watch for you know i said at the muster
i said aim this book at yourself and i
said aim these things to yourself when
you hear stuff like this when i hear
stuff like this i aim it at myself
don't be afraid of new ideas and this is
what an intelligent man
with an open mind can demolish a bad
idea by reasoned argument
and and what i like about that is
i always say to myself dave if you come
to me with a plan or you come to me with
an idea and i can't convince you that
your plan isn't good or that there's a
hole in it there's a
problem then there's there's something
going on here maybe it's my ego maybe
it's my emotions maybe i just don't like
you but if i can't explain to you
why your plan isn't good and the only
thing i can finally say is you know what
we're doing it my way
the only way i can overcome you is by
you know um well a catchphrase which
would be like we've we always done it
this way
or we need to stick with the plan right
those are just catch phrases and that's
what i'm gonna say or i just say we know
dave's always got his own freaking
dave's always on his own freaking
program like i can i can ridicule you or
i can just get mad
that's what we see yeah that third level
too i forgot what the middle one was
when he talked about the meaningless
catchphrase and then the third one like
resorting to anger yeah you know it's
basically just degrees of your ego of
just being out of control because the
first one's like i'm just going to kind
of be dismissive of you by a catchphrase
of jacob talks to me about an idea and i
say something like uh you know
you know
here comes the new guy with a bread idea
you know like just trying to kind of
push you off and then if you persist and
we kind of get to the second level and
i've got some other response that isn't
working at the end all i've got left is
i get mad at you
and if i outrank you like the military
this whole military experiment then i
automatically win i automatically win
because i'll just shut you up because
i'm now mad and i'm just going to resort
to what i got is hey uh why don't you
just go back to your desk and let me let
me do some let me let me lead for a
little while here since i'm in charge
yeah and then you just kind of walk away
and that's the end of it what you want
to do is you want to be the jeff glover
of ideas so jeff glover will go out on
the mat with you and you he will let you
put him in any position because he
doesn't care he knows jiu-jitsu and he
can get out of it
and if he doesn't get out of it he's so
if you tap him out he's like oh yeah
that was a good way to finish because
because you know you started with the
rear naked choke and you were able to
finish it jocko good job you know like
he doesn't care he's his ego is not
involved at all
and he doesn't care and most of the time
by the way he gets out because he knows
the truth so that's why i try and be
when someone confronts me with an idea
i'm stoked
oh you you seem to got me off balance
awesome either i can recover myself
because i have good information or a
better perspective and we can discuss it
logically and i can say oh yeah and i
can point it out to you or you caught me
off balance because i'm wrong and i had
a hole in my game and it didn't make any
sense
so i'm actually happy about that
open your mind
uh fast forward a little this inbreeding
of the uneducated however was resisted
by by the later massey committee who
depressed by what they found considered
that
one the general education of cadets
should be continued
too few young officers showed any
capacity for command this was an
assessment of what they were doing
three there was too much drill too much
rigid discipline and too much cramming
for marks
number four the instructors were
mediocre and selected for prowess at
games and smartness rather than for
their knowledge of the subject they had
to teach or their qualifications as
teachers
much the same and again this was an
assessment sorry i skipped it but this
was an assessment that got done of how
they were training the military the army
officers and and it says much the same
picture has been painted of britannia
forerunner of the royal naval college at
dartmouth dartmouth again the emphasis
was on blind obedience
sport and ceremonial with scant regard
to intellectual pursuits and little
pride in knowing one's job
[Laughter]
you know what's funny
as soon as you say something like
there's too much drill as soon as you
say you know if you're
maybe you're thinking hey man we're
spending a lot of time just doing this
like stupid drill stuff there's someone
that's like oh you don't understand the
disc but the people and that's what this
whole actually that's what this whole
book is about
this whole book is about the people that
when you threaten the the the norm and
you threaten the hierarchy you threaten
the things that provide them with their
security which is rigid discipline when
you threaten those things they get mad
and they attack yeah they get mad
you started this whole part and you used
a word and i think you pulled it from
the book twice and then i think you said
it once and i wrote it down was
all this is a feature of the system like
all this is a feature and he i think he
was using it initially in this part of
and if i'm just trying to paraphrase
what you said was
hey
listen you know the bell curve has kind
of exists everywhere but there is
something a little unique about those
that sort of make it to this level of
senior leadership we're talking about
generals and admirals or you know lords
or whatever but there's something a
little different about the ones that
make it up to that level
and how it isn't quite just the same
bell curve of everybody else where
you've got some smart people some you
know middle of the road folks maybe some
other folks
and what i've been trying to
think in my mind about what that is is
kind of what you described is what's
unique about those people those people
have figured out how to navigate the
system
this thing that we're all living in
because when you join the military i
don't know how smart you are or dumb or
i don't care who or what you are what
rank what service or where you came from
at the beginning you you're just trying
to figure out how the system works
and if you figure out go oh
this class that i mean that jack was in
charge of
at the end i get my choice of assignment
strictly based on my gpa
oh okay guess
guess what a lot of folks are going to
do that figure that out i'm going to get
i'm just going to worry about the great
oh
jocko's got this thing for drill it's
this thing
cool
and so when you say hey we're going to
go drill yeah let let's go do some more
drill or hey dave you got some free time
what do you want to do i i think hey
boss you know what we should do we
should go drill and all of a sudden i
kind of start maneuvering my way through
the system to appeal to what i know is
what you want and i kind of wrote down
some of the words of
of things that are are appealing brute
force is appealing it's appealing it
sounds cool you know what doesn't sound
cool
deception
like i'm gonna i'm gonna take an
indirect approach well that
that doesn't sound cool um
caring about people doesn't sound cool
being nice doesn't sound cool being an
intellectual for the military no that
you know blowing things up sounds cool
being an intellectual doesn't and if i
can figure out early on what is going to
appeal to you whoever my bosses or that
school is or or the intent is or the
system and that's our system this is
about
the bell curve is different at the top
because they figured out how to navigate
the system what the system wants and
what the system wants is whoever's in
charge that thing that appeals to them
which is things like
whatever
what would you rather have someone who
who um
a pragmatic thinker who's willing to to
um
give up on its plan and go in a
different direction or someone who never
gives up
you know like how many times we talk are
we to talk about the direct approach
and not forget the idea that that
that sounds appealing it sounds right
i'm just gonna come at him and tell him
the truth
i suppose i i'm gonna play the long game
i'm gonna think strategically i'm gonna
keep my ego in check i'm gonna consider
that i might be wrong and i'm gonna uh
move slowly in this direction until we
come to the logical conclusion or i'm
just gonna attack this target and run it
over
and the ones that figure out the system
and have it navigate that it makes sense
that at the top
there actually is a different bell curve
of people than those of us at the
beginning who actually some of us don't
figure out how to navigate that system
yeah yeah and well i don't know if i
necessarily fully agree with you um
because
i think that the system
the system but you're going to agree
with me i say this anyways but look at
that that system there's people that
that learn how to figure out the system
because they lack the ability to
actually transit through the system on
their own merit right so that's one
group of people there's another group of
people that travel transit through the
system and promote through the system
because they're good and as we mentioned
at the beginning of this you and i both
work for incredible officers at all
levels
incredible senior enlisted at all levels
and some of those
the people that were awesome they made
it through the system the system worked
they didn't have to they didn't have to
play a game they'd have to manipulate
they they did what they knew they should
do and they went up through the system
and they were great but there's another
group of people that's a group of people
you're talking about that
they don't have the capability but they
figure out you know what admiral mcguire
we were talking one day
and he said
he said you know we i think he he had
gone over to see some
the seals secure or the bud students
secure from hell week and he came back i
didn't go with him for whatever reason
he came back he says you know
if hell week one proves one thing like
you're you're you're pretty tough
you know because he sees these guys
after six days of freaking you know
being awake and doing physical stuff he
goes yeah proves one thing you're pretty
tough and i actually said back to him i
said
you know there's a group of people that
also
go go through hell week and make it
through whole week and what it proves is
that they figured out how to how to get
through
because there's things you can do in
hell week
and oh it's it's actually a little
different now when i went through hell
week
you you just
if you didn't carry the head if you
didn't put your head under the freaking
boat i know this doesn't sound like that
big of a deal but you carry these
freaking boats on your head for a week
straight and guys permanently lose some
guys not all guys some guys permanently
lose their hair on the top of their head
because it gets so that freaking boat is
just grinding on it
and and it's it hurts hurts your neck
hurts your head you have freaking scabs
on the top of your head whatever
but there's some guys that figure out
how to now you can't just take your head
off the boat
but you also
you know maybe you don't quite
put as much into it
there's guys that figure out you you
know when you're carrying the boat at a
low ready which is just carrying at your
side which again doesn't seem like a big
deal until they fill it with sand and
water and also it's you know half your
back and
so so you can kind of
slack off a little bit
and so there's guys that figure out
where to come in on a run where they're
going to get the least amount of
attention they figure out where to be in
the chow hall line where no one's going
to pay any attention to them
they figure out how to get through and
and i would say hell week is probably a
pretty small amount of those people
but
you certainly would see a couple guys
and you'd go man how does he look
fresh right now
well-rested some guys you look oh that
guy's fresh because he's a badass some
guys you'd be thinking how's that dude
look fresh right now what just happened
so
yeah in any system there's gonna be a
way to
maneuver and manipulate through the
system where if you don't have the chops
to actually get it done you can still
get through it and yeah obviously i do
agree with that and i think that's why
there is
a little bit more of a contrast at the
top
than there might be elsewhere when
you're looking at the types the
different types of people and the
contrast to his point usually doesn't
reveal itself until you get to this
and he illustrates all these
catastrophic things and you're looking
back you're thinking how could someone
be in that position do the things that
they're doing and that's really i think
what you're describing is
there's two different types of people
that can get to that place now the ones
that are doing it like you said on their
merits they still have to be doing a
good job you can't not know how to
maneuver in the system and be terrible
at what you're doing
but
you can find your way to kind of
maneuver up that ladder maneuver inside
of that system
and and
be in that category of people that
sometimes will all go oh well he's he's
a general he must be awesome well
this is how this person got there but
you you won't see that
it won't be revealed as to what this
person is until it's in he's in one of
those situations and i think that
contrast that he's alluding to is like
it's a little bit different there
is more stark because at the at the very
beginning
none of us have figured either of those
things out yet we're still figuring out
hey what do we need to do and how does
the system work and
you should blend the two i want to i
want to work inside the system i don't
want to buck against the system and be
so resistant to the system that the
system
gets rid of me yeah well i was about to
say what about those
leaders that are incredible leaders
they're dynamic they have these great
personalities they have good tactical
sense but they can't play the game at
all i can't play the game at all right
and now they didn't never get promoted
and they have no influence yep that's
right i mean tommy hackworth didn't play
hackword played the freaking game for a
long time he played the game like
massively
massively and he loved it he wasn't even
playing the game he was in the game he
was the he was the freaking player
and he's an example of a guy that he he
played the system he got those jobs he
did those things but he also was highly
skilled as a leader yes and there's
plenty of people that would have done
and there's plenty of people that did
the exact same thing as hackworth minus
the leadership capability yeah there was
a hard job what would you call it hard
fill billet right yeah in the seal teams
we had the same thing you got a hard
fill billet somewhere after you do your
hard fill billet they literally will
give you any job you want well cool hey
i'm not going to promote it on that but
jump on that hard fill billet
get done with that they send you
overseas unaccompanied for two years
boom
and you come back now there's some guys
that do that
because they're freaking good team
players and they're you know what i
don't someone else have to do this you
know what my my kids just left for
college i'm gonna be i don't have
anything to worry about for two years
boom i'm gonna go take this hard-filled
billet take one for the team there's
some people that do it for that reason
totally
there's some people do it because
they're going i can get promoted next
after this so get my check in the box
and that piece when you talk about the
leadership all i'm thinking is
he actually cares about the people yeah
he actually cares about the people
around him and so that maneuver to gain
the influence
is is
is by design to be able to help people
yeah
because he knows there's peace there's
features in the system he's got to
protect them from yes it's it's all
about the intent yes and although
you can smell intent
the system has a much harder time
smelling intense the system has a much
harder time smelling intent look they
look at dave burke and they look at
jocko and they both win overseas took a
hard fill billet
jocko was doing it because he wanted to
get promoted dave was doing it because
he had uh you know his kids had just
left for for a college and so he felt
like it was a good time and he could
take the strain off of someone else that
might have kids still at home yeah what
do they see on the paper they don't see
any of that i can't see it they can't
see that intent they can't see it if
they knew us they could smell it yeah
but they don't get close enough on the
promotion board some people around you
know
people around you know for sure
uh fast forward a little bit general
robert e lee admitted that the greatest
mistake of my life was taking a military
education
and general stillwell said it is common
knowledge that an army officer has a
one-track mind that he is personally
interested in stirring up wars so that
he can get a promotion and be decorated
and that he has an extraordinarily
limited education with no appreciation
to the finer things in life that's a
pretty a heavy statement again are there
some guys like that absolutely that's
not the majority for sure
fast forward a little bit more the
saddest feature of anti-intellectualism
is that it often reflects an actual
suppression of the intellectual activity
rather than any lack of ability
this is suggested by the rapidity with
which so many military men rush into
print as soon as they have retired let's
talk about people writing books
evidently there was something waiting to
get out
unfortunately as liddell hart points out
a lifetime of having to curb the
expression of original thought
culminates so often in there being
nothing left to express
so this is talking about i mean this guy
is writing this book in 1976 so he's
talking about guys in world war one
world war ii as soon as they get out of
the military they write these books
a guy like b.h lodell hart
he writes books because he had all this
stuff pen up
and he also got out early because he had
so much stuff pen out pen up inside of
his head this guy's saying a lot of
times by the time they get out there's
no freaking creative thought left
there's no new ideas left
research on the relationship between
mental activity and cerebral blood blood
flow adds to point that the old belief
that the brain like muscle
atrophies from prolonged disuse but
perhaps this touches upon the real cause
of military incompetence age since
traditionally promotion is dependent
upon seniority commanders generals and
above have tended to be old and since
thinking memory intelligence and special
senses all deteriorate with age then
maybe bad generals are just old generals
again he's making an argument well maybe
these guys are just old maybe that's our
problem
another contribution to the incompetence
tied up with age was the unhelpful
tendency to sack forcibly retire or
otherwise curtail the promotion of those
young officers who unwisely failed to
conceal their
their lights beneath bushels of
conformity
so
real quick on the getting old part this
is something that i was i and i think i
talked about it on on the academy
i heard that interview
with kasparov the chess player
and the interviewer acts actually i
think it was lex friedman lex asked him
maybe it was lex i think lex asked him
not in a direct way but basically could
you beat magnus carlson who's right now
like this phenom
and kasparov said no
and of the part of the part of the
answer which is what i talked about on
the academy was part of the reason is
because
um magnus has got to see everything that
kasparov does and study him it's like
jiu jitsu guys now they're like you know
you got to
you it took you seven years to figure
out the 50 50 position
i i got to learn that in 20 minutes on
youtube right so i can start building
off that immediately and that's the same
thing with kasparov is that is that
magnus carlsen has seen all of his moves
and everyone else's moves and studied
him in books so he's already building
off of taller platform but also kasparov
said i think kasparov was like 55 60
something like this maybe a little bit
older he's like yeah well i'm older now
yeah and that brain ain't working as
good so that which really surprised me
because i didn't understand that i
thought hey you get older you get
smarter
and once you reach a certain point now
you're heading in the other direction so
that's what he's bringing up he's saying
hey could that be part of it
um
he says such was the case of major
general jfc fuller on december 13th 1933
fuller one of the most intellectually
gifted men ever to serve in the british
army was placed on the retired list
this waste of talent resulted from the
prejudice aroused by his fully borne out
prophecies and the fact that he had
dared to criticize those less gifted
than him
now let's think about that we could be
mad at the military for kicking him out
but guess what he didn't do
play the game he didn't play the game
he's also criticizing people who's
probably telling him that they're dumb
yeah yeah he didn't play the game
properly so if he would have played the
game a little bit
and not been a prophet as bhlelhart said
instead been a leader maybe he could
have slowly got some senior officer to
understand it make it his id and all of
a sudden his ideas are getting pushed
forward by the seniority instead he gets
put on the freaking retired list yeah
and
this this thing that you've you've
mentioned in the past probably isn't
exactly a fit here but that idea of hey
if you're so smart why aren't you
winning
you know like what a freaking great
quote just yeah just this idea of
of if if you're as smart as you think
you are why can't you figure out how to
maneuver through this this labyrinth of
chaos yeah you know which by the way if
you're so smart how hard how hard could
it be you haven't figured this out yet
right you haven't figured this out yet
that question which i originally asked
myself when i was like an e4 in the seal
teams when i wasn't getting promoted and
other guys were was hey wait a second if
you're so smart freaking their rambo why
aren't you getting pro why aren't you
winning what's wrong with you yeah you
idiot but that's one of my favorite
questions to ask people
hey because they'll be telling me this
and this and this and this and this
complaint this other complaint and how
this is messed up and the other thing's
messed up and it's like if you're so
smart if you're so freaking smart why
haven't you just maneuvered through the
system yeah what's wrong with you
and by the way um
fuller
like they were gonna bring him back in
and they offered him something and the
other guys pro i mean he's just like
made up made it too hard on himself man
smartest what did they say what did you
say one of the most intellectually
gifted men ever to serve in the british
army
but he wasn't quite winning was he
because he got freaking put on the
retired list
and look maybe there was some situation
where they were asking him to do you
know hey we don't want to see another
people like but even if that happens
what do you do you say okay cool how can
i rephrase this how can i adjust my
message what people can i make allies
if you're so freaking smart then go in
um
fast forward yet another way
in which age determines incompetence is
through the voluntary resignation of
intelligent young officers according to
janowitz a study of us army lieutenant
suggests that the brighter ones resign
as soon as they have completed their
obligate obligatory service
while those less well-equipped remain
mm-hmm that's again is that all across
the board absolutely not and there's
freaking incredible officers that are
smarter than any civilian out there that
stay in the military and they do 20 30
40 years for sure
and there's also some guys that are
going
you know i got my paycheck coming in
every two weeks kind of regardless of
what i do
mama stick it out and there's a little
joke in the military too that that at
each level you you move up that's
that there's some some truth to it which
is hey you got promoted yeah all the
good guys got out yeah that's why i got
promoted you know hey hey dave you made
major yeah all the best captains
left so the wrinkler had no choice so
the joke about that is you know there's
some truth
absolutely some truth of
well i'm glad these two guys bailed
because i would have been competing with
them and i don't know if i would have
made the cut if they stuck around yeah
but they're left with me so i'm gonna
i'm gonna get that promotion yep there's
absolutely some level of truth to that
someone that looks around the military
you know one of the one of the things
that made me uh
one of the one of the things that had a
little bit of a
influence on my decision to retire
was it's a communist
environment right it's a communist
environment
you
you're getting the same
promotion rate i mean what did you get
advanced early a couple of times
no no early promotions in the marine
corps everything's on time so so that
that that's that's true yeah is right so
it doesn't matter what you do so you
were you were an f-18 pilot you were top
gunners are you all these things and how
how much faster do you advance than
someone that was uh you know running
whatever
freaking supply depot in the middle of
nowhere
how much earlier did you get advanced
zero days zero days
zero days
so i got
advanced early one time which is which
was like i only know of one other person
i only know of one person that got
promoted early twice there's probably
more but one of the i know one other
person that got advanced early he got
advanced early twice and that's delta
charlie by the way
yeah delta charlie talk about playing
the game dc he was maneuvered
um and awesome but so so
i'm looking around and look was i the
best guy absolutely not but i looked
around some guys i said wait a second
of all the stuff i've done i've been
going on back-to-back deployments doing
whatever i can do
doing a good job
in combat doing a good job just doing
just doing a good job right look i
wasn't the best but i wasn't doing bad
but then i'd look at some other
knucklehead
that was actually doing bad who had a
bad reputation you know some knucklehead
that you know wasn't even in the game
and guess what he's getting promoted oh
i got promoted one year ahead of that
way and by the way a bunch of other
great guys that i knew are getting
promoted the same time as him i was like
man
that is freaking not right
it wasn't as much of a meritocracy as it
should have been and that bummed me out
it bummed me out because i was looking
at probably another seven years before i
would have been in charge of something
again
which is a long time to be waiting to
get in charge what are you chuckling
that over there charles no every time
you said uh that bummed me out for some
reason that's always been funny to me
yeah
yeah it did though they bummed me out
bumped out sorry about the thing does
things not bum you out they do but that
expression is funny especially when you
say it
check uh it's a little bit of a
communist system it's a little bit of a
socialist system where if you stay in
and you check the boxes whether you
check those boxes with freaking
big giant checks or you check them with
a little nick mark it doesn't matter you
checked it you're good you're good
uh notwithstanding these considerations
ages far from being a complete
explanation of military incompetence
four
there have been plenty of old generals
and some remarkably inept young ones
or sorry there's been plenty of able old
generals and some remarkably inept young
ones so he's saying look even though old
people might have a harder time there's
been freaking incredible generals that
were super old and there's been young
generals that were idiots so that
argument doesn't really hold
as vax noted the generals of 80
generals who were sick of body and even
in mind have won important victories so
there you go age you can't put all this
stuff on age but let us look at another
aspect of what appears to be in
intellectual incompetence the urge to
pontificate
in accordance with the principle that
nature abhors a vacuum ignorance tends
to evoke pontification in those that
wish to conceal their lack of knowledge
or for whom ignorance of the facts means
that they feel free to express strongly
held beliefs of a contrary nature
this is an interesting one and it really
if you
uh you ever seen a movie the sixth sense
i know you have echo you seen it dave i
have
and you know when you get to the end you
look back and you see all the things so
obvious this one right here when i read
this i was like oh man this is good you
look back at your career and you think
of all these people that like to
pontificate and you think i knew that
guy was an idiot
well he wouldn't shut up
right wouldn't shut up
wait what is pontificate it's talking
talking carrying on and talking
especially about things that you don't
really know too much about it's also not
a compliment like if somebody like hey
what's like working with the jocko i'm
like he likes to pontificate a lot
that's not it that's not me saying he's
a big thinker it's me like he likes to
hear himself talk he wastes a lot of
time thinking out loud and it's all at
the end you look back like that was a
complete waste of time so it's not a
good thing i'd say uh maybe you the
expression hot air right oh that guy's
filled with a lot of hot air this is a
nice way of saying okay that guy's
filled with a lot of oh it's not even a
nice way of saying it as david pointed
out you don't say someone hey joco did a
great job pontificating at them at the
monster you wouldn't say that
there's usually some timing associated
with it too that he wants to chime in
like we need to go step out and he's
like hey
and he wants to start talking and yeah
and we're forced to sit here and listen
to him and it's not just what he's
saying it's also the time at which he's
saying it you're just thinking dude
okay i guess we're gonna sit here and
listen and talk yeah okay i i always
thought it was like kind of thinking and
talking but in a good way i thought it
was like hey let's get to the bottom
list let's explore it you know but maybe
okay i get it now
um
so with quantification in a calling
where the accuracy of communication may
be a matter of life or death the
predispo position to pontificate is a
dangerous liability by the way
we have something called the second law
of combat leadership it's simple
the subtitle that is simple clear
concise communication so pontification
is the opposite of that
oddly enough
unfortunately such a predis disposition
will be the strong be will be strongest
in those like headmasters judges prison
governors and senior military commanders
who for too long have been in a position
to lord over their fellow men
unfortunately such a predisposition will
also be strong as an authoritarian
organizations where the preservation of
apparent omni omniscience
by those above may be deemed more
important than the truth
so this is that senior leader
that basically no one will tell them to
be quiet
and you know what's even worse than that
people sit there with a big smile on
their face nodding their heads because
you know oh jack was talking oh yes boss
that sounds great plus please tell us
more it's all a lie
they're really thinking shut up dude
that's what's going on yeah
and some of those people are going oh
if i ever get to that this is how i'm
going to get to that spot i'm going to
do that i'm going to follow like that's
what i do that's that's how the system
rewards me right how how i can navigate
in a system is i can do the same thing
it's going to be awesome i can't wait
till i'm enjoying people have to listen
to listen to me i can't wait i i know
this uh
because we sit here and talk for hours
at a time as our freaking job not only
here but an echelon front that's our
actual job is to talk to people i mean
at essentia actually our job a lot is to
listen as well but
um you you know people might get the
impression that oh you know jacob like
at the muster when i'm um guess what i'm
on stage i'm talking that's what we're
doing
um come to an echelon front meeting
you know see who's talking like see how
much i'm talking right it's come to uh
task in a bruiser meeting see how much
i'm talking
come to a
seal team 7 echo platoon meeting when i
was a team commander am i the one that's
talking the whole time absolutely not
so although we talk a lot here this is
not the norm
[Music]
uh but the important thing about
pontification is that
though an intellectual exercise
its origins are emotional
closely allied to pontification and no
less hazardous
is cognitive dissonance
now it just
just just to talk about dissonance just
the word
um it means
technically what it means is an
inharmonious sound that's technically
what it means it's it's sounds that
don't match together so like if you play
piano there's certain there's certain
keys of the piano you can hit at the
same time and you uh right guitar you
can hit certain strings and certainly
doesn't sound right that's because they
don't match because they're incongruent
they're in disagreement those noises are
in disagreement so
cognitive dissonance means that you have
things in your head that don't agree
there's things in your head that don't
agree
and it's what people do and how people
handle things in their head that don't
agree this is the important part
because with any situation that you have
there's gonna be different sides to
every argument there's gonna be
different sides there's gonna be if
we're gonna go attack a target part of
your brain should be saying like okay
this looks like something we can get
done part of it is saying okay this
looks like there's a lot of risks as
well
you've got two different things in your
head two different
incongruent congruent thoughts in your
head they're not the same so so
cognitive dissonance means i have two
things in my head that don't match
how do you handle it that's the question
how do you handle it
uh this uncomfortable mental state
arises when a person possesses knowledge
or beliefs which conflict with a
decision he has made so that's going
even one step further i've made a
decision
and now i'm getting some different
information
the falling hypothetical situation
should make the matter plain a heavy
smoker experiences dissonance because
the knowledge that he smokes is
inconsistent with the
knowledge that smoking causes cancer
since he finds it impossible to give up
cigarettes he tries to reduce dissonance
by concentrating on justifications for
smoking and ignoring
evidence for its risks he may tell
himself that the revenue from tobacco
helps the government that it keeps his
weight down and that it is a manly
sociable habit at the same time he may
well refrain from reading the latest
report on the relationship between
smoking and lung cancer if on the other
hand he cannot avoid being confronted by
tiresome statistics he may well strive
to reduce dissonance by telling himself
and others that the correlation between
smoking and cancer could just as well be
taken to signify that people who are
going to get cancer anyway tend to smoke
in order to ward off the disease
so you're just telling yourself lies
to trying to try and even out that
disagreement in your own head
since it was first propounded by
festinger in 1957 dissonance theory has
given rise to a large number of
empirical studies
through the though the precise nature of
the underlying psychological processes
is far from clear there are certain
conclusions which could have serious
implications for military decision
making they may be summarized by saying
that quote once the decision has been
made and the person is committed to a
given course of action the psychological
situation changes decisively
there is less emphasis on objectivity
and there is more partiality and bias in
the way in which the person views and
evaluates the alternatives end quote in
other words decision making may well be
followed by a period of mental activity
that could be described as at the very
least somewhat one-sided
yeah dude you i was
like i got halfway into that sentence
and you were just shaking your head
because you know you've seen this happen
totally and he you know he you did that
list earlier and i the one that was
coming back to as you're talking about
in the hard part about it is you can you
can i know what he's going to say before
he's even saying it now you know what's
coming when he's describing this says
here's the plan jack goes down in the
front sends me a report go hey boss
things are mes things are a mess down
here and i'm like
no they're not they're not that bad
they're not that bad we're fine we need
to we're just going to keep doing this
you're like hey listen it's got much
worse
and
rationalization all those words but the
the the willingness to just ignore the
truth because it is inconvenient with
the conclusion i've already drawn and
how quickly i can go
you know what his feedback is
you know it's based on what he's seen
it's not really he doesn't know what's
going on it doesn't have a big picture
so we're going to keep you plus jacques
was kind of emotional yeah plus he's
he's you know it just started he doesn't
have that much combat experience he's
getting shot at yeah he's freaking out
but this is he doesn't see what i'm
trying to i mean you just rationalize
that [__] all day all day all day um you
know the here's another thing you were
talking about
uh like who do you like what is it what
is the the cool military leader what do
we think of here's one
uh
would you say i want to promote this guy
who has a lot of self-doubt
right are you we're not promoting that
guy but what's interesting is i am so
filled with self-doubt that when i come
up with a plan and dave burke sends a
report back from the front line he's
like hey jocko we got heavy resistance
i'm like okay i must have been wrong
i'm missing something does this mean i'm
not going to freaking push forward no it
doesn't mean that but it means i'm i'm
actually doing the opposite of this this
trying to balance out the dissonance i'm
paying more attention because i think i
might be wrong
the irony in that in that truth the
irony is is how you've described you
having a reputation of being so decisive
in the your time in the teams was based
on that that belief that you could be
wrong which is why you've made these
incremental decisions that didn't over
commit to the end
was actually driven by what you just
described as you know you the the term
self-doubt doesn't have like this
positive you know connotation but it's
like oh hey
i bet you there's a bunch of things i
don't know so you know what i shouldn't
do over commit
which was
based on you having a reputation of
being decisive
which people can equate to
um
the opposite of self-doubt i'm so secure
in my my decision-making process that i
know the outcome and this is the course
that we're going on it's exactly the
opposite of what you're doing which is
the incremental piece and go ahead got
some feedback yeah boss here's some
feedback this was a this blew up on our
face we ran into a brick wall uh three
vehicles are down and we can't keep keep
going
and you're gonna go oh
we need to do something different right
now as opposed to
hey just keep going
we're we're sticking to the plan yeah
and that's true not only on the
battlefield but it's also true in a
conversation be with another human being
it's also true when i say
hey dave
you know what's your plan with this
client or or here's how i think we
should approach this client i'm not
saying this is how we should approach
the client i'm like hey i got an idea of
what we could do with this client what
do you think it's having a freaking open
mind is what it is
and the minute you know i've
i said that a while ago like our mod
people's minds they're they're either
opening or closing
and we can have some control over that
you can control whether you leave your
mind open or whether you let your mind
close at least i think but let me let me
rephrase that i think people have the
ability to control whether they open
their mind but they don't have as much
control over if you're not conscious
about your mind just close up and
oftentimes we're looking our cognitive
bias is to just close that mind i don't
want to hear what dave has to say so i
think what we have to do is you have to
form a habit of trying to keep your mind
open prying it open and i had to keep
this going back to the mustard you know
i went back to that old conversation how
often do i have to admit that i'm wrong
yeah and you know i asked the entire
crowd at their muster how often do you
think i have to admit that i'm wrong and
everyone thinks i'm humble and they go
all the time yeah probably 10 times a
day you admit that i'm wrong and i'm
like no almost never i almost never
admit that i'm wrong why do i almost
never admit that i'm wrong because i
never go into a conversation
telling everyone that i'm right or even
thinking that i'm right yeah
so therefore i don't go in the in the
conversation saying dave we need to do
this with the client
and then dave goes well actually i talk
to the client here's what's going on
here's what they actually need and i
have to go damn it i was wrong no one
said i say hey dave here's what i'm
thinking what do you think yeah that's
one example of a hundred conversations
that i have where i could go in there
and try and be right but instead i go in
there with an open mind instead of a
closed mind
it's so counter-intuitive to think the
connection between never being wrong or
never having to or rarely having to
admit that you're wrong isn't because
you're right all the time it's because
you never entrench yourself in a
position and
you know the saying could be could be
said for why you and
i uh whatever the better word is for
argue for disagree like how often do you
and jacob disagree on on a plan it's
like well almost never like oh you must
be perfectly aligned on everything no i
just i haven't predetermined the next 37
steps that we're going to do neither is
he and we'll move and i'll do it his way
sometimes we'll do it my will get
somebody else's input and none of us are
committed to an outcome and the reason
why we're disa we don't disagree on what
we should do is that neither one of us
come in with the conclusion of what we
should do
and how counterintuitive that is is is
the idea that the more committed you are
the less you will um
the less you'll admit that you're wrong
and
the exact opposite is true is the reason
i have to admit that i'm wrong very
often because i don't walk in thinking
that i'm right yeah and actually you and
i are very committed to an outcome who
are committed to having the best
possible outcome we can have
with nothing to do with which outcome
right or which course
how we get there it's like oh this is
the best possible outcome dave came up
with a way to make this the best outcome
outcome that sounds awesome i'm in we'll
do that all day long yeah
uh fast forward a little bit
by the way
you get the book i haven't said that yet
today so we're skipping all kinds of
stuff but there's so much information
this book those commanders with weak
egos
with over strong needs for approval and
the most closed minds will be the very
ones least able to tolerate the nagging
doubts of cognitive dissonance in other
words it will be the it will be the
least rational
who are the most likely to reduce
dissonance
by ignoring unpalatable intelligence
so
the person who the the person who can't
tolerate those doubts
will just shut them out
which is a horrible thing
uh fast forward a little bit no better
example is this an afforded by
townsend's occupational cuts since the
advance up the tigris was totally
unjustified by the facts of which he was
fully aware his dissonance when disaster
struck must have been extreme and to a
man of his egotistical nature depend
demanding of instant resolution so again
in the face of much contrary evidence he
withdrew into cut the wiser and possible
course of retreating to basra would have
been a greater admission of the lack of
justification for his previous decision
by the same token once inside cut
nothing would budge him because to break
out even to assist those who had been
sent to release him would have
emphasized his lack of justification for
being there in the first place in short
an inability to admit one has been in
the wrong will be greater the more wrong
one has been and the more wrong one has
been the more bizarre will be the
subsequent
attempts to justify the unjustifiable
this is when people this is when you're
looking at people they just seem like
they're freaking crazy
we can now see the relationship between
pontification and cognitive dissonance
pontification is one of the ways in
which people try to resolve their
dissidence
or sorry dissonance
but there is another aspect of decision
making no less hazardous it is it's
riskiness
research has shown that people vary in
the degree to which they adjust the
riskiness of their decisions to the
realities of the external situations
individuals who become anxious under
conditions of stress or who are prone to
be defensive and deny anything that
threatens their self self-esteem
tend to be bad at judging whether the
risks they take or the caution they
display are justified by the possible
outcomes of their decisions
for example they might well adopt the
same degree of caution whether placing a
small bet
getting married or starting a nuclear
war
there is a sad irony about this state of
affairs for it means that those people
who are most sensitive to the success or
failure of a decision will be the very
ones who make the biggest mistakes
conversely less anxious individuals will
act more rationally because they are
able to gr devote greater attention to
the realities with which they are
confronted
so when you got people that are nervous
about decision making they're nervous
about failing they're nervous about oh i
better win this
it's like what you see happen in sports
right basketball teams up by 10 12
points
they're they're doing good they go up by
20 points they start hitting three
pointers there's no pressure anymore
they're just like letting it fly
that's when they do their best so
someone that can go into a situation and
say yep there's some risks here but
i'm not worried if i look stupid
whatever i'm doing the best i can cool
and then you look at the rational
situation if you're like oh my god i'm
gonna look like such an idiot if i don't
get this right this is gonna be horrible
guess where your focus is it's not on
the realities of the situation it's not
on rationale rationalizing a good
decision it's just focused on how bad
you're going to look if you screw it up
so you make a bad decision yeah so
you're more likely to screw it up
that's crazy
one psychologist has said under stress
men are more likely to act irrationally
to strike out blindly or even to freeze
into stupid immobility
that's what stress does to people i've
seen it you know when you see that i've
seen it in like acute cases where
someone's stressed out in combat and
they kind of lock up and you got to kind
of shake them out of it i've also seen
it
on
you if you look at it broadly over a
full deployment
and you see
people that
you
that are usually pretty solid and they
start either getting angry they start
lashing out they start making dumb
decisions you're like this stress is
getting to you man that's what's going
on you got to back them off a little bit
but why should an anxious and defensive
individuals those who are those who have
the most to lose act more irrationally
than those less afflicted afflicted by
neurosis two reasons have been advanced
the first has been well stated by
deutsch some guy i don't know who it is
didn't look it up sorry nervousness
the need to respond quickly because of
the fear one will lose either the desire
or ability to respond enhances the
likelihood that a response will be
triggered off by an insufficient
stimulus and thus makes for instability
you know it's a freaking um good example
of that
uh
someone you put someone in like a
a shooter situation with
simunition and you're like all right go
in the house if they've never done it
before and they're super nervous they're
freaking shooting the first person that
they see whether they hold the weapon or
not right they're gonna be quick to
respond with fear because they're
nervous
and the more you train them to that the
better they'll get the second reason why
a proportion of
of people will make irrational decisions
whose riskiness is unrelated to reality
is because being neurotic they will
strive to maintain an image of
themselves as either quote bold and
daring
end quote or quote
as careful and judicious decision makers
end quote and the urge to sustain their
particular conceit will take precedence
over the need to behave realistically
so
luckily for me like you were talking
dave about me making small decisions
luckily i figured that out because i
like being a person that's known as
decisive but luckily i figured out i
could look and appear and be decisive by
making small decisions
so i didn't have to try and figure
everything out everything at once which
is what i recommend people do
he closes out this chapter saying since
mil since decision making is by
definition a cognitive process then
obviously the oldest theory
is
is in one sense a truism but it but it
by no means follows that the simple
hypothesis of low intelligence fits the
bill again this whole chapter is about
intelligence so he's saying listen
decision making is about how fast you
can think and your cognitive capability
but it doesn't cover everything
on the contrary by looking further into
the nature of decision making process we
are compelled to entertain another
rather different possibility namely that
the apparent intellectual failings of
some military commanders are due not to
lack of intelligence but to their
feelings
cognitive dissonance
pontification denial risk-taking and
anti-intellectual intellectualism are
all in reality more concerned with
emotion
than with intelligence
which i i mean that well it's not
another another thing we say at the
mustard who here has made a great
decision when they were super emotional
no one raises their hand that's why we
teach people to detach from their
emotions so that you can make good
decisions do you detach 100 no but you
need to detach so they're not driving
your decision-making process the
susceptibility to cognitive dissonance
dissonance the tendency to pontificate
and the inability to adjust the
riskiness of decisions to the real
situation
are a product of such neurotic
disabilities as extreme anxiety under
stress low self-esteem
nervousness the need for approval and
general defensiveness
these it seems over and above his level
of intelligence are the factors which
interfere with what a man decides to do
given in a given situation
i think he made a pretty good case for
that not about how smart you are
smart plays some role i mean obviously
if you're an idiot you can make a bunch
of bad decisions but
that's not the that's not the major
number in this equation
most people are making bad decisions
based on their emotions based on their
feelings based on their psychology
and this whole thing ties into dave this
is what you were getting at earlier you
got about a whole chapter here talking
about what you what you started the road
you started to go down this chapter is
called military organizations
and it says military organizations make
for military incompetence in two ways
directly by forcing their members to act
in a fashion that is not always
conducive to military success
and indirectly by attracting selecting
and promoting a minority of people with
particular defects of intellect and
personality so this is what you were
talking about yeah
how the system will set up to promote
and this is going one step further you
talked about how the system can promote
people they can figure out how their way
to get through it it also can attract
people like this yeah
people that are looking for a system
that they can figure out how to get
through
the root cause of all this is that since
men are not
by nature all that well equipped for
aggression on a grand scale they have
had to develop a complex of rules
conventions and ways of thinking which
in the course of time ossify into
outmoded tradition curious ritual
inappropriate dogma and that bane of
some military organizations irrelevant
[__] which we had a conversation on
here about chicken [__] chicken [__] and
[__] i think chicken [__] is the
term that's used nowadays he's using the
term [__] and he actually throughout
this calls it bull i think i'm gonna
call it [__] most the time he calls
it [__] here but this idea of
[__] chicken [__] stuff that you're
polishing your belt buckle you're
polishing your boots you're doing all
these things these things in the
military either called chicken [__] or
[__]
but
those things are a huge part of some
military organizations and as we're
going to find there's some reasons for
it but there's also when it gets out of
hand uh fast forward a little bit
broadly speaking human activities may be
regarded as falling into
one or the other of two main groups
those which are directly instinctual and
those which are not so we all got some
things that we instinctively want to do
into the first which involves what have
been succinctly described as the three
f's
feeding fighting and reproduction
fall such robust pastimes as pugilism
professional pie eating prostitution and
soldiering so look we got these three
f's
feeding fighting and reproduction
and from that we get things like boxing
we get things like professional pie
eating and chefs and restaurants we also
get prostitution we also get soldiering
those are all kind of you can marry
those up from where those came from
in the second group fall all those other
vocations which though sometimes
subservient the basic drives do not have
as their end product the original
cons
consumatory response
besides this most important difference
the instinctional the instinctual
vocations have three other
characteristics which differentiate them
from those in the second category
they may involve
unlearned patterns of behavior are
motivated by crude if powerful emotions
fear lust and rage and are designed to
culminate in an unlearned response of a
distinctly physical kind so those are
the three f's right there
you got powerful emotions tied to them
fear lust and rage
and they
where they get you is something physical
you're eating you're fighting or you're
reproducing
um
he goes into prostitution a little bit
prostitution is easy because the
transformation of an unlearned drive
into a money-making career is more a
matter of realizing a potential than
seriously modifying nature
and then he goes into this thing about
this guy who interviewed prostitutes and
this one prostitute said i'd been
working in a factory for five years
before i realized i was sitting on a
fortune all the time
i kind of had to throw that quote in
there
it goes on
down the same path
talking about a professional soldier
the original purpose of intra-species
aggression is not destruction but
distribution so why do why do people
fight why do animals fight because we
got you gotta freaking stay away from me
a little bit you can't get too close to
me not too close to my resources not too
close to my
woman like you need to get your own
activities going this is my ao this is
my area of operations
in lower forms of life the instinct of
aggression is controlled by a language
of signs and counter signs so that
everyone remains spread out with a
minimum amount of bloodshed
moreover those animals best equipped to
do each other and injury are also
those with the most effective controls
against so doing a dog tackles enough to
encroach upon a rival's territory may
become involved in a noisy scuffle but
has only to drop his tail roll over and
urinate to terminate the attack upon his
person right so that's what animals do
and even you know going out elk hunting
the elk
they fight hard and occasionally they do
kill each other but most of the time
they just hey man like i'm dominant you
go away and the guy's like cool
so that's the way it's supposed to be
you're supposed to be able to sort of
surrender back up give some space and
hey that makes sense so that's the
difference i the point that he's trying
to bait
bear here is hey a prostitute
she's still doing something that just
makes sense on an instinctual level
right
whereas humans with war
things all of a sudden aren't so
instinctual anymore because now look if
it was in caveman days and you came into
my territory i'd probably beat you up
and you'd run away and i'm not going to
waste any energy for trying to go catch
you i don't care you just stay away from
me
well when we get to war now it's a lot
different so he goes into that a little
bit
humans they have made up for a lack of
natural weapons by acquiring some far
more deadly artificial ones right we
don't have horns on our head we don't
have big teeth where we can rip each
other apart sure we can choke each other
if we have jiu-jitsu we don't like
but we don't have these things so we
make other weapons right clubs
spears
knives
guns
missiles
um
yet other difficulties and this is where
this is where you're gonna take
everything we just talked about and now
we're gonna take it into this military
context and this is something that i
have talked about before
i've talked about the difference of
decentralized command
and
when you have centralized command
and the fact that when decentralized
command started to come to fruition is
when you didn't have conscripts anymore
you didn't have you had people that you
could say all right here's what we're
trying to make happen go make it happen
you have to say this is what you need to
go to go do go do it and if you don't do
it i'm going to shoot you that's a
different type of discipline
it's imposed discipline versus
unit discipline
so we're going to get into that a little
bit here yet other difficulties have
been posed by the sheer size of human
warring groups with the transition from
small parties of hostile tribesmen to
large mercenary armies came problems of
motivation and control
right so if you if it was just the the
five of us and our clan and we were just
defending i didn't need to motivate echo
to do his job if he didn't do his job we
were all gonna get overrun and we're all
gonna die so there was no real reason
for me to have to
impose discipline on you we just had it
we just we knew that we had to fight
together we knew if we got overrun they
were going to come and take our food and
take our women and that was game over
for us so there wasn't any real need to
to quote motivate you
but things are bigger now since the
history of warfare is largely that of
many
who
though through poverty or the press gang
were forced to take up arms for a cause
which few could even comprehend the
evoking and direction of aggression
called for special measures so once we
have an army where echo doesn't really
quite sure why the hell he knew when it
was our cave our little area and we were
defending our our tribe he understood
that but once he's like all of a sudden
he's in a foreign country
and i'm giving him a uh
uh
a musket
and i'm saying okay dude we're gonna
fight he's kind of thinking wait a
second i don't even live anywhere near
here
so now we need to come up with some
special measures to get echo to direct
his aggression towards the enemy
how do we do that these included devices
to ensure group cohesion to incite
hostility
to enforce obedience and to suppress
mutiny because once again i put i take
echo on a ship give them a sword and be
like okay dude we're gonna go and fight
these people you've never seen before
they're not close to your family they're
not close to your area of operations
and not only do i need to get you to
hate them i need to make sure you don't
freaking just turn that sword on me and
cut my head off
because it doesn't make any sense right
it doesn't make any sense to echo
charles who's got his tribe it doesn't
make any sense for you to go to some
other place and fight so how are we
going to make that happen well
we got to make group cohesion we got to
incite hostility against the enemy we
got to enforce
obedience and make sure we don't have a
mutiny
they also included means whereby the
intentions of leaders could be
translated into a concerted action by
followers in short it called for two
other components of militarism
firstly a system of rewards and
punishment
of rank medals battle emblems and prize
money that's what's i'm going to dangle
in front of you carrot
of confidential reports court martials
and the lash there's the stick don't do
what i tell you the court martial you
i'm going to whip you whatever
and secondly
a system of orders and over learned
learned drills whereby complex patterns
of behavior could be set in motion by
the briefest of instructions
so i'm actually going to train you i
like how echo charles become my soldier
today right you like that
uh i'm going to train you so i got to
end up with a pattern of behavior that
becomes instilled in you
no less important for a theory of
military incompetence is the means
whereby militarism is administered and
its continuity insured originally so now
we're going to get into this originally
since combat was largely a matter of
brute force we must suppose that the
strongest came to the top in fighting as
in prostitution vital statistics gained
the day a sort of natural selection
according to the criteria that were
essentially physical
but in the course of time the growing
number of personnel involved and
improvements in technique required some
revision of earlier criteria a
distinction became necessary between
organizers and the organized between the
brains and the brawn
so now just the fact that echo's the
biggest strongest guy it doesn't
necessarily mean that's going to make
the difference in the battle because we
got a bunch of people and if i can
organize more people against or if the
enemy organizes five people just to
fight echo echo's going down so i need
to get some people to support echo now
we got a freaking army
to this end
civil government might have been
expected to construct armies in which
the dichotomies in which such
dichotomies obtained one might have
expected that officers would have been
chosen for their brains and the
hierarchy of command based upon merit
and professional expertise so echo you
and i we're on the same tribe we form an
army we take all the big guys and we're
putting you guys in the front lines that
makes sense right because you're the
you're the ones that are going to crush
the enemy we're also going to take our
smartest dude and be like hey you're
really good at organizing people you've
got a loud voice you come up with good
plans cool dave you're going to run this
battalion over here and dave's like cool
got it
that's the way we should do it dave's
proved himself he's smart right so
that's what we're doing that's what we
think we're doing that's what makes
sense to do
right that clearly makes sense
however
for
example in britain civil government did
nothing of the kind
by methods of purchase and nomination
the control of the army was given over
to men who with nothing to gain from
revolution would remain the loyal
apolitical supporters of the existing
regime professional ability energy and
dedication of the job counted for little
so that's not how they selected they
didn't say hey who's better at decision
making you know
echo
you know what you're gonna be front
lines dave we you know you got you got
those quick thoughts we're putting you
in in command what the british do no you
know what they said who's gonna be loyal
who can pay the most will put you in
command
by the way so check this out how does
that how does that
how does that work
dave you have money to buy
a commission
what do you think of the system
what do you think of it yeah i like this
you like the system yeah and you want to
importantly you want to maintain the
system yes absolutely echo you're kind
of broke
[Music]
right yeah
you don't you don't really like the
system because you haven't been able to
succeed and you probably want to change
the system so you know what i'm not
putting you in charge
i'm going to put the guy in charge that
succeeded in the system that wants the
status quo
he wants to protect he's going to fight
and he's going to use you to fight to
protect what he's already got
status and money
that's the dynamic
we that's what he that's what he means
when he says
uh
men who with nothing to gain from
revolution would remain loyal dave's
going to remain loyal he can pay for
this yeah the reason he can pay for this
because he's done all right in the
system how do i benefit from a
revolution here yeah
i don't want that at all no not at all
so you're willing to so once i give you
a position and i give you authority yeah
you can actually use your authority now
to maintain the status quo which is what
you want
and by the way you can also impose your
status quo because if you guys go take
over another chunk of land guess who's
going to get it not echo he fought for
it but dave's gonna get it
maybe we'll give dave let me give echo a
little sliver of you know maybe get some
a little bit of a little bit of gold in
your a little bit of booty for you
but dave's gonna get the land
so we'll keep you a little bit happy but
dave wants us to succeed and dave's
willing to sacrifice a bunch of you
a bunch of echoes for this situation
um fast forward a little bit the
essential nature of militarism should
now be clear we see it as an ever
increasing web of rules restrictions and
constraints presided over by an elite
one of whose motives was to preserve the
status quo exactly what i just said how
do i keep echo in line
here's the rules here's your uniform
here's what you got to do if you step
out of line guess what's going to happen
you're getting you're getting the lash
you're getting punished you're getting
no pay you're getting bread and water
so that's what we set up
but this incompetence is augmented by
another factor namely the
characteristics of some of those
attracted to millet to the military
let us examine this hypothesis by modern
standards and viewed from the outside
the nature of militarism may not seem
very attractive including as it does a
number of attributes which are
positively repellent to those who value
freedom egalitarianism and
and creative as opposed to destructive
ends
so so if you think about what the
military is hey you're gonna go you're
gonna follow orders you're gonna have to
dress the way you get told to dress
you're gonna have to cut your hair the
way you'd get told to cut your hair you
have to wake up when they tell you to
wake up you're going to go to bed when
they tell you to go to bed like
if you're a person that values personal
freedom
why are you going in there
why is that happening
if you want to create things in in the
world why are you going in the military
you go in the military to destroy things
there was a guy
a seal team one
he was a vietnam guy and he said i
joined he said when he left seal team
one he said i joined the navy in 19
whatever it was i joined the navy in
1968 so i could kill people from my
country
i was like yes
but right that's
that that's attracting a certain person
type of person not someone that wants to
create
someone that wants to destroy
uh he said why then do people join the
army
and are there some characteristics of
the military which have a positively
magnetic attraction for those whose
subsequent performance may be deemed
incompetent
so who are we bringing in here he makes
a a
comparison to alcoholics anonymous
he says
alcoholic anomalous
anonymous
can attract people an individual with
particular problems of a psychological
kind may be expected to gravitate
towards a group which he recognizes not
only as containing fellow sufferers but
also as having developed effective ways
of dealing with special needs of its
members
the therapeutic gain from such behavior
during the second world war has been
noted by robert holt he wrote
it was a common clinical observation
during the war that military service was
an unusually good environment for men
who lacked inner controls
the combination of absolute security
a strong institutional parent substitute
on whom one could lean unobtrusively and
socially approved outlets for aggression
provided a form of social control that
allowed impulses to be expressed in
acceptable ways
by the way when you join the seal teams
you're joining the seal team so you can
kill people or
at a very minimum
you're joining the seal teams knowing
that you may have to kill people
if you're going to join the seal teams
you're going to go all through that all
that there's got to be some actual in my
opinion desire to kill people that's
what you want to do
right dave you didn't go in the marine
corps thinking uh
hey
i'd like to fly a jet no you want to fly
a jet right that's what you want to do
this is an acceptable way that you can
go fly a jet did you want to get in a
dog fight
yes
and what's the outcome of a dog fight
either win or you lose and what happens
to the loser
yeah the loser dies loser dies the loser
dies so
here all these military people are
signing up for
their aggression to be
expressed in an acceptable way yeah
surrounded by surrounded by people who
see it the same way yeah well that's the
thing you look at alcoholics like well
you know these other these other people
deal with it and you look at the
military like i kind of wanna yeah that
sounds like a cool way to go i also
understand why you feel the way you do
why you think the way you do and and
that scene that he set with that
you can see it's so easy to see that
connection so easy to see that
connection yeah
uh
he says even a troop of baboons
contrives a rigid dominance hierarchy
wherein each male knows its place it's
kind of like the military it's very nice
get in there and you can see when some
people in the military when they when
they're that baboon that gets their spot
in the hierarchy and they want to flex
it on everybody oh you can see those
people all day long
and again is this everyone in the
military absolutely not it's absolutely
not no but there's a piece of that
formalization of that hierarchy
and in the military i'm sure it's the
same way with you that there is still an
unspoken hierarchy there is a there's a
a pecking order that isn't written down
you know there's a roster that we don't
write on the board and go okay you know
jocko's one echoes two dave's three it
doesn't say that but everybody kind of
knows definitely and and if it's not
pure there's at least some group some
caddy like a couple guys here a couple
guys here and everybody knows it and
but the system can offset that a little
bit by creating
well it utilizes
that
um
deliberate hierarchy which means like
maybe maybe dave's like seven
kind of sucks
but
i do whatever i can do a maneuver and
i'd actually i get promoted or i get a
task or i get actually some deliberate
hierarchical authority right and now i
can kind of like now you can exactly my
revenge
yes because i hey hey we all know where
i was but that was unwritten but i'm in
charge now yeah and then the psychology
of that power which sort of
fixes the problem with the unspoken
hierarchy and the things that you know
in that you know those baboons don't
have a chart they just know
and there's nothing that number seven is
going to do to go well i got a formal
piece over here that sort of allows me
to impose my will on you
and i mean i've been writing things on
self-esteem ego the 20 different
versions of that word that he's used so
far in this book which all comes down to
the insecurity all those different words
that he's using
the military delivers some authority
for the people that have that that is
kind of undeniable in this system and
again not everybody just like you said
this is not everybody but it is there it
is there
there's
there's nothing worse
than when somebody who thinks they
should be in charge
actually gets in charge
those people are the worst the people
that sit there and think they're just
they're just fuming they're thinking
i should be wrong i could do such a much
better job and that's what their
thoughts are
and when they actually get put in charge
they're a freaking disaster they're a
nightmare
[Laughter]
oh that they become the head baboon as
at a human level armies resemble the
authoritarian family group just as the
ethos of an upper class victorian family
totally forbade any show of aggression
by the child toward its parents but
encouraged organized aggression towards
contemporaries in such school pursuits
as boxing and sanctioned bullying so in
the army the slightest hint of
insubordination i.e aggression directed
towards the superior is severely
punished while aggression towards the
enemy is encouraged and rewarded
gotta set that up
gotta keep it under control
from a
psychological point of view therefore
militarism strives to maintain that
paradoxical state of affairs where
feeling angry
may well be totally split off from
aggression
one in which a soldier is required to
suppress his aggression towards his
superiors whom he may loathe while
venting it upon a hypothetical enemy
towards whom he will
may well entertain no hostile feelings
[Laughter]
this the classic example of this
unorthodox behavior occurred on
christmas day 1914 when british and
german troops joined together
for
um
convivialities in no man's land this
guy's vocabulary is very impressive by
the way
needless to say these reprehensible
flickerings of humanity were quickly
stamped out by the generals on both
sides and we all we all know what
happened the germans and the brits were
like we're not fighting anymore we went
played but we played soccer
and then the generals like no you will
bomb them yeah roger that
it is just because the business of a
soldier is destruction and violence that
need
to take general precautions against
disorder becomes so pressing
because you really you got a bunch of
freaking
your you're training people to be
aggressive and you've got to somehow
make sure they don't point that
aggression at you
the aspects in question may be subsumed
under the general if faintly imp
impolite heading of [__]
so important is this curious phenomenon
that it deserves a section to itself so
now we have a chapter that's called
[__] which i already mentioned this
is the little stupid things that you're
doing
so this is covered in this next section
this next chapter which is entitled
[__] chicken [__] whatever
um according to eric partridge the word
was coined by australian soldiers in
1916 coming from a country whose armed
forces have always been relatively free
of from this element of militarism they
were evidently so struck by the
excessive spit and polish of the british
army that they felt moved to give it a
label
going a little further back it is
possible that the expression has its
origin in a
bull
the false hair piece worn by women
between
1690 and 1770 this would be consistent
with the fact that modern
dictionaries define bull as quote a
ludicrous jest
a self-contradictory statement to cheat
empty talk absurd fussiness over dress
end quote whatever its etymological
significance such definitions certainly
capture the military nature of bull one
of the most astonishing apparently
irrational and yet significant aspects
of militarism one which connotes an
attitude of mind a pattern of behavior
as and an end product
as implied by the old jingle
quote if it moves salute it if it
doesn't move pick it up if you can't
pick it up paint it end quote
the phenomenon involves ritualistic
observance of the dominance submission
relate relationships of the military
hierarchy extreme orderliness and a
preoccupation with outward appearances
this is what we call chicken [__] this
is why
uh the term painting rocks comes from
the marine corps right i think so i mean
i've heard that term a thousand times i
can't say that i know for sure but i
think that's right i i can i can
definitely say i have seen way more
white painted rocks on marine corps
bases than any other base yes
right so what does that mean they means
that if they'll take rocks and paint
them white and black oh and it's like
[__] like that
just painting some rocks okay don't get
painted some rocks before
it's not instead boys painted some rocks
bro he's painted some rocks so uh
in in the military manifestations of
bull range from such minor apparent
absurdities as the polishing of the
backs of cap badges so what that means
echo is you're polishing something
that's never going to be seen but
someone's going to inspect it
it can't be seen but you're going to do
it
the blancoing of trees
for a forthcoming
general generals inspection i'd look up
bloncoin because i didn't know what it
was so blanco was a
like a powdered paint that they used to
issue so you could camouflage things but
eventually of course took it to the
extreme and now we want all the trees to
be the same color so we're gonna mix
this powdered paint which is a military
thing and we're going to paint the trees
so they're all going to be whatever gray
that's the kind of that's some chicken
[__] stuff going on right there
uh besides its emphasis on appearance
and it's constraining aspects of
[__] also involves a compulsive
concern with cleanliness in this respect
alone it may achieve impressive levels
of irrationality to make to make it
white webbing equipment might be boiled
almost to the point of destruction while
the blankets that one sleeps that the
owner sleeps in stay unwashed for weeks
there are of course good arguments for
[__] so here's some reasons why it
exists some of the positive reasons it
ensures a level of ordinance orderliness
cleanliness discipline personal pride
obedience and morale which so it seems
could not be reached in any other means
i.e by reasoned as opposed to compulsive
behavior
by the same token it achieves a level of
uniformity that makes for a solid area
and group cohesiveness so there's some
good reasons for it
however the case against it is also
strong it is time wasting excruciatingly
boring for all those with more than the
most mediocre intellect and a poor
substitute for thought
since it aims to govern behavior by a
set of rules and defines a rigid program
for different occasions it cannot meet
the unanticipated event so you're
getting trained not to think
you went do did you go to ocs yeah okay
when i went to navy ocs the belt buckles
that we got we had to polish the coating
off there's a coating that comes on the
belt buckles echo charles
that keeps it shiny
no matter what like you can it's going
to keep shiny you actually polish that
off
yeah so that it can get uh eroded so
that you have to polish it more
that's some chicken [__] some [__]
right there homes we had um anodized and
non-anodized anodized is the permanent
thing that like is always brass or shiny
yeah you are not a lot of you have
anodized gear so all of your stuff your
belt buckles everything none of it could
be anodized that was reserved for like
some other people
and so you had to by the unanodized and
then shine it to make it look like it
was
yes good use of time wait we had to
manually
unanimous right the freaking belt
buckles the next level it's you could
see it slowly coming off you'd be
sitting there with a cotton swab in just
for hours
see even echo is confused by this that's
kind of nonsense it's total sunsets it's
called brass oh brasso yeah you
definitely use brasso yeah that's what
got it off right
ah like any compulsive symptom
[__] and its cousins
ritual dogma and superstition have put
themselves so far beyond reason thought
that they can that they create
resistance to change and the acceptance
of new ideas take military drill this
starts as a skill adapted to a reality
situation
right we used to have to do close order
drill for combat
it develops into a rigid pattern of
behavior by becoming automatic takes the
load off of memory so you drill that and
we still do this today you do you don't
call it military drill but when you're
doing immediate action drills with your
weapon you're learning how to wrap tack
and bang you're learning how to solve
problems without having to think about
them takes the load off the memory once
learned it is it is directed by
processes of which we are scarcely
conscious and which leave the limited
channel capacity of conscious experience
mercifully free to deal with other more
pressing events that's why you can
reload your weapon without having to
think about it and that way you can
figure out where i'm going to maneuver
my element to less next that's drill
that's good
it is drilled in such a sense which
ensures that most motorists
let off the handbrake before engaging
the clutch and that most speakers
construct their sentences according to
the rules of language right we don't
have to think about that military drills
started in this way the devices which
could eventually weld together a group
of uneducated peasants into a single
corporate machine that did what it was
told this was all good except for one
thing ritualization implying the
tendency to transform means to an ends
thus the battle drill of one error
becomes the ceremonial drill of another
what started out as a functionally
useful maneuver becomes a highly
stereotyped pattern of movements on the
barrick square in itself this may no be
bad this may
be no bad thing so this is where these
things come from that's where they came
from when you see the people doing the
close order drill like the marine corps
silent drill team it used to have a
purpose
and it's not a bad thing necessarily
ceremonial ceremonial can be pleasing to
the eye
and anodyne for taxpayers and even on
occasions a device for raising
charitable funds
dude you're talking about the blue
angels being 100 yeah yeah and
and i mean that in like he's described
in a good way right right yeah it's a
good way it's and it's based on at one
point hey we're going to fly together my
wingman's going to be a you know
whatever very close to me yep but now
we're going to take
what is there seven of them at flying
six six now we're gonna take six
aircraft we'll be three inches from each
other and
it's taken to the extreme and it has
some benefits it could kind of recruit
people it's going to be the taxpayers
can see that we've got something and we
can raise money so it's a positive thing
but unfortunately ceremonial drill like
other forms of [__] is addictive and
by being so usurps the time and energy
which should be devoted to other more
adaptive pastimes it then becomes a
substitute for doing something else as
when the conservative element in the
brigade of guards resisted the adopting
of new battle drill because it would
interfere with their existing ceremonial
procedures so now we're starting to say
hey we can't do that because that's not
how we do our ceremonial stuff
fast forward a little bit as a factor in
fighting efficiency bull has also been
unhelpful in the navy if we were if we
assume that one of the main purposes of
a navy is to defeat the enemy and that
is in the past anyway achieved by shell
fire it might be supposed that much time
would have been spent on practicing
gunnery but in the british navy in the
years before the first world war ship
commanders were actively discouraged
from gunnery practice because the smoke
might mark the paintwork and soil the
gleaming
decks the price for this was paid at
jutland hey did you
when did you came in the marine corps in
what 1994 commission 94 yeah commission
94 did you start your camis
oh
yeah
i got into the era of starch okay i
started before we we obviously don't do
that anymore i had to go back in the
memory banks yes yes totally
we started our freaking cameo totally in
the seal teams for almost my entire
career you will you had a pair of stars
yes and i remember when the marine corps
at one point they stopped starting i was
like they are so freaking squared away
yes and i remember that time i mean you
had your set of starched inspection
ready games and when you brought them in
they would ask you the level of starch
that you wanted yes and you'd say
galactic
[Laughter]
i don't want to be able to move i want
this to be body armor yes i had starch
camis that would stop a freaking 762 by
39. about that when you said it because
we went away from it you know sort of
pre-pre-war right was pre-war so i was
unfortunate that's even more impressive
yes
i could see him doing it after september
11th maybe two years later be like all
right we gotta freaking stop these no
you actually did it before the war
started which shows you somebody this is
why we know we have some good officers
out there right because somebody looked
and said wait why am i seeing this
freaking lance corporal over here this
starch set of camis and not to like
overdo it on this but that piece you
said is actually really important and
using that example is a good example
because the new cameras the marine corps
got not only were they not starch they
were designed to be washed and not even
ironed
which was somebody going hey
ironing your camis
is dumb
and it takes a long time and we're going
down the path if we're going to start
measuring marines based on how well they
iron their cammies which is a skill that
i don't care about yes and so it wasn't
just no more starches you could take
them out of the wash and flat you know
you know
slap them out and put them on and they
weren't wrinkled they didn't look like
crap and
it is an example of what you just
described was like they're actually some
good people going this is stupid this is
chicken [__] and we're not doing this
yes that is outstanding awesome somebody
that needs to be a chicken [__] review
board if i was benevolent dictator of
america i would have a chicken [__]
review board for each branch of the
service and then i'd have a chief
chicken [__] review board officer who
would be like a mustang freaking udt guy
from nom
also when i came in the marine corps
there was no name tags
did you do were you in that air i was
yeah so you were just you were just
staff sergeant what what was your name
my name is staff sergeant you can just
call me staff sergeant that was that was
freaking outstanding that was pretty
cool
um
fast forward a little bit now that we've
touched upon some of the more obvious
manifestations of the phenomenon let us
examine its deeper causes and relevance
to the central thesis of this book okay
so why where does this change come from
for a start it seems to be a natural
product of authoritarian hierarchical
struck organizations secondly though
it's outward and visible signs are
manifold they have three common
denominators the first is constraint
we're trying to constrain people
the second is deception which sounds a
little bit weird
and the third is
substitution for thought the deception
part is like oh we can have you doing
this instead of doing something else
the constraint is we're going to control
you and the substitution for thought is
we don't want you thinking
fast forward a little bit here
perhaps the
single most important feature of bull
is its capacity to allay anxiety
so
and
i'm just going to get into it at a
conscious rational level
orderliness cleanliness punctuality and
discipline clearly make for efficiency
the knowledge that one belongs to an
organization which puts a premium on
these laudable traits that one's rifle
will fire and there is a key for the
bully beef tin obviously makes for
confidence so these are really positive
things about
about this level of discipline
at a conscious rational level therefore
even those aspects of bowl which reflect
the grossest exaggeration of these
traits must seem like steps in the right
direction
this confidence of course may be may be
displaced
that a commander insists upon meticulous
attention to detail down to the last
shining button is no guarantee that his
strategical thinking is anything other
than pure aisle
indeed he could well be unwittingly
substituting a lesser for a more
important area of generalship that's the
substituting part
look as we were saying earlier dave i
might not be the sharpest tool in the
shed but if i can polish this
belt buckle and i can put on this
uniform and i can get my platoon to do
all that correctly i'm gonna look good
nevertheless there are good grounds for
believing that those situations in which
[__] flourishes are ones
in which it reduces anxiety because
orderliness is fairly vital to survival
again the imposed uniformity which is
part and parcel of the [__]
obviously makes for group cohesiveness
and that we're all in it together
feeling which combats fear
we must suppose too that the height and
conformity which it imposes will like
other forms of perceived conformity
encourage people through a diffusion of
responsibility to perform acts which
they might otherwise avoid so we've
built a team and we've used this to
build a team which is okay
i have a common bond with people that
went through ocs that we sat around in
policies it's a real thing
yet another useful feature of [__]
and so it has been said is its role as a
distractor and time filler according to
this theory a mind preoccupied with
buttons and toe caps has little room for
gloomy forebodings
the point is well made by a b campbell
when writing of naval customs quote it
is the guiding principle of naval
service that the ship's company should
be constantly employed and this is the
reason apart from the necessity for
scrupulous cleanliness why there is so
much scrubbing of decks and polishing of
bright work this is making people have
dumb [__] to do because we want the
groups to be troops to be busy
in the same context this writer compares
naval and civilian routine
there's a reason i read this whole
section
it is safe to say that there are many
jobs many shore job routine
routines which destroy initiative
this also applies to many factory
workers but is not so in the navy a
routine job builds up a blue jacket's
character as to why the end quote as to
why the naval and civilian characters
should require such dramatically
different treatments campbell refers to
the moments of danger which occur for
the former but not the later ladder
this begs of course several questions so
he's saying
this this writer is saying that in the
navy
all this [__] work
builds character building but for in the
civilian world um they don't need it
they don't need it and it hurts their
initiative
the reason that it's okay is because in
the navy you've got to face all these
threats
danger
and he says it confuses loss of
initiative and blind obedience with the
building of character and makes the
unwarranted assumption that naval
ratings face greater danger than many
civilians including merchant seamen
steeple jacks racing motorists mountain
climbers single-handed yacht-men
coal miners matadors not one of whom has
to fortify his character by polishing
grass or scrubbing wood
it would perhaps be truer
to say
that since the imposing of bull upon
troops serves to reduce initiative it
will thereby increase the feeling of
dependency which they have toward their
superiors this in turn will increase
their obedience and loyalty
so we're getting a little
brainwashing going on you do what i tell
you to do you do it over and over again
you become dependent on me telling you
what to do
and that's what i want i don't want to
have any initiative i don't want you
thinking for yourself i just want you
doing what i tell you to do that's why
when i am a tyrannical leader or author
authoritarian leader i'm super concerned
about your freaking buttons
finally at a conscious rational level
there are aspects of bull which may well
help combat social anxieties in military
men gorgeous uniforms martial music
prancing horses and even being saluted
are obviously bomb to tender egos and by
promoting soldierly pride do much to
offset the hostility and ridicule to
which the military are from time to time
subjected to by those in other walks of
life
but there is another less obvious reason
for bull namely that it serves to reduce
deeper seated feelings of anxiety which
may well have their origins in events
unrelated to here and now of which the
subject
remains blissfully unaware that's where
he starts getting a little psychological
it's a psychological reference there
that we have things in our subconscious
that make us laugh a certain way
and one of the things he's saying is
people that people that like things to
be super orderly
super or orderly they don't like change
they don't like when bad things happen
they don't like when things that they
can't control they don't like those
things
and we're gonna get to this but what
kind of person you want in the military
someone that can handle change and
unexpected things this is the wrong
person so if you're a person that looks
in the military and goes damn i want a
uniform i can just wear what they tell
me to wear i can polish it and nothing
changes and that's what i want
that's great on the parade field it
sucks in combat
the most extreme examples of this
phenomenon occur in obsessive compulsive
neurosis a condition which the patient
feels compelled to follow a pattern of
ritualistic thoughts and acts that these
often include such bizarre symptoms as
compulsive hand washing this is ocd a
preoccupation with timing and counting
recurrent ruminative ideas stereotyped
verbal utterings
and always standing with one toes
absolutely in line has obvious
significance for more military versions
of the malaise
you remember a while ago talking about
the degrees of insane right everyone's
everyone's insane because everyone's
reality is a little bit different well
everyone has different degrees of
how
ocd they are
and everyone has some level maybe some
people are not you know .01 but you got
a spectrum
and the the case here is that if you
look at the military and you see people
that are all uniform and you see that
everything's clean
you look at that as a type of
environment i might want to go into
because i'm kind of like that
and that's how you end up with people in
this zone
what do you got i just i wrote it down i
was like this guy is such a good right
he called it bomb to the tender ego like
it's such a great
it's such great medicine for that like
oh
buttons are shiny yes boots are lined up
on the line perfectly
height order
everything is how i want it and that
that is such good medicine for me you
know for my tendencies where they came
from and then just like you said is and
i made the reference of the blue angels
from a from a
they're literally called the flight
demonstration team
but if you have the mindset that this is
a reflection of combat if this is a
reflection of the challenges you're
going to face in the real world
i mean
the disconnect there cb seems like it'd
be so obvious but all those stories that
he's telling in the first three sections
we did to this there's people going oh
i
might we close order we have the best
closer drill platoon we're going to be
the best platoon in combat
dude yeah it's that
i wish that this the disconnect was
talking about something else but the end
state of all this is
real people die at the end of all these
stories which is the worst part about it
and then and then the ultimate
manifestation of that is is world war
one of like we're gonna get
online just like we did on the parade
deck we're literally gonna get in the
line and move in in a line
it's crazy
i guess insane maybe it's a better word
yeah
um
yeah speaking of the degrees of which
you're ocd he says
such symptoms are not of course confined
to the chronic sick so you don't
necessarily have to have some big issue
milder forms may well occur in normal
population during times of stress bead
counting foot tapping and the mouthing
of dogma
like the compulsion to make things clean
and tidy during periods of menstruation
well-known palliatives for the stressed
psyche
so this is something that you see people
doing when they're stressed they'll say
the lord's prayer or whatever
except for rose
thug rose sure remember when she fought
for the first time against
that chinese girl what's her name
if you know it
and the oh no it was against johanna it
was just against johanna
and so johanna dave was like just on a
tear destroying everyone
and she had this super hostile
aggressive attitude just you know
getting people's faces and she'd been
crushing people and she fought thug rose
and they squared off in the face off and
and johanna's getting all crazy making
the mean face and everything
and thug rosie just
just straight normal face just saying
the lord's prayer freaky look
thug rose
um
he says uh let us not beat around the
bush at the risk of offending those with
delicate susceptibilities or though or
who themselves have problems in these
areas it must be said that they involve
four matters of primary importance in
every human life sex elimination eating
and death
these are things that cause us
concern
the greatest anxieties concern death and
unconstrained disorder since the two are
inextricably
related a defense against one is a
defense against the other also this is
perhaps the crux of the origins of
[__]
so we're afraid to die
death is a form of disorder so we want
to get everything in order let us
approach this from another standpoint
whenever
whatever its particular form of [__]
results in a state of affairs which is
opposed to what many people would regard
as a primary source of delight
the natural diversity of nature
towards such diversity it's in it is imp
implacably hostile
it is no exaggeration to say that this
uh this aspect of militarism is
dedicated to the ironing out of
differences the efficiency with which it
destroys variety imposes uniformity is
matched only by its demand for
conformity so we are going against
nature when you're making everything the
same
and nature's death is part of nature
uh this is against uniqueness uniqueness
as market value not for nothing does
current advertising for the quote best
car in the world make only one specific
claim that no two rolls royces are alike
so there's
we're devaluing uniqueness
but bull inverts these values it
worships homogeneity and frowns on
deviance whether it's toe caps buttons
or dressing by the left hair length kit
inspection or marching feet the
quintessence the quintessence of
perfection resides in conformity to a
regulation
pattern this conformity is the product
of constraint
it seems that since bowl is primarily
concerned with substituting pattern for
ramen randomness it evidently reduces
anxiety by the reduction of uncertainty
so there's a whole idea psychologically
that we just want to make things more
certain less random how do we do that
well we
just make everything the same
if i'm a person that is has anxiety and
fear of the unknown what am i going to
do let's start trying to make everything
the same
that's cool
if you're on the parade field that type
of personality is actually awesome if
you're on the parade field that type of
personality that doesn't want anything
to be shocking is a nightmare on the
battlefield
anyone who doubts these soothing effects
of bull has only to consider two other
situations of frightening uncertainty
marriage and death
few who have played even a minor role in
these events would deny the emotional
support that comes from the time-honored
ritual of weddings and funerals i never
thought of that before there's a reason
you got to do this this way here it is
let's face it if you didn't set that day
on the wedding if you didn't set that
day and have a bunch of people invited
and there wasn't a thing going on
you probably get 50 less weddings
because people are freaking out right
they're like i'm not going through with
this
um
two overlapping theories can be invoked
the argument is simple living organisms
are complex patterns which persist for a
time within the essential disorder from
which they came into which they will
with a with equal uncertainty return so
you live
you're nothing and then these random
freaking biological components fall into
a pattern for a certain period of time
and then they ball break apart and
you're dead
which is a really bizarre way of him
saying what i just said i think he gets
an f on simplicity on that one
whether it is a single cell the
integrated systems of the total organism
or the external social order there
exists regulators controls and
constraints whose function it is to
preserve the pattern to keep it from
keep to keep this from that to maintain
purity and separateness this holds as
true for biological process as it does
for the construction of an urban sewage
system you have to put controls around
things
indeed life can be construed as a fight
for orderliness
in the course of which much behavior
both voluntary and involuntary both
external and internal is directed to
this end
the laws and rules of hygiene
prophylaxis antibio antibodies rejection
mechanisms adrenaline secretion and new
year's resolutions are just some of the
devices which aim to stem their
perpetual drift toward disorder
so that's what life is you have to stay
in order to stay alive
and you do like you work out to keep
everything in order you try and eat
right to keep everything in order you
make new year's resolutions to try and
keep everything in order you you clean
your teeth to try and keep everything in
order it's a fight it's a fight to keep
things in order it is of course a losing
battle
as
oscar wilde said good intentions are
useless attempts to meddle with the laws
of nature
uh bull
[__] represents an extreme
manifestation of a general unnecessary
propensity on the part of living systems
to resist randomness
this would account for the fact that the
satorial
aspects of the syndrome are concerned
with removing dirt
with maintaining separateness with
keeping green green and white white with
preserving the status quo keeping hair
short brass shiny rifles clean and with
maintaining uniformity by written orders
shouted commands and other behavioral
constraints
but
like waking consciousness in contrast to
the dream and normality in contrast to
psychosis [__] makes its effect by
constraint upon the creativity of
thought he just said all that other
stuff that i just said for that i'm
sorry it took a little longer i should
have should have skipped a little bit
more
but
all that stuff of trying to maintain
order is negatively impacting creativity
that's what it's doing and the more you
focus on that stuff the less creative
you're going to be
[__] may be regarded as an
organization's response to the threat of
its disintegration
right so if you're in the military
and you don't keep order there's
actually a threat of your organization
falling apart
in the military this threat has two
sources the external enemy and the
aggressive impulses of its own members
in either case the greater the threat
the greater the constraints
which means when you add
conscripts that you were trying to get
to fight you had to freaking tighten
those people up you had to you had to
keep it super rigid
you get into special operations that's
probably the least rigid because
everyone volunteered three or four times
to get to that point where now hey i
want to be here so there's much less
constraints
so that's where we're at
now
at this point dixon who wrote this book
uh goes into a bitter he goes he goes
down some freud activities here sigmund
freud which is
um
if you don't know anything about freud
freud was a cocaine addict i need to say
at least uh he was kind of a liar and a
bit of a quack um
he basically spewed out all kinds of
crazy
theories
and and and a majority of them i don't
know if i'm out of line saying this but
i'm pretty sure i don't think i am a
majority of them were wrong a majority
of them were just bat [__] crazy like
just weird
theories that
he thought up but
so
and i would tell you that dixon
well this is again he wrote this in 1976
this hadn't progressed people didn't
have as much knowledge freud had more
people hadn't understood how what a
freaking disaster freud was
but
he but freud did just like a
broken clock is right twice a day freud
did come up with some concepts that are
that are still used and one of them is
just that we have a subconscious now
what freud thought was that our
subconscious was
was uh
basically built before the age of five
based on your erogenous zones and all
this weird stuff right and that you it's
just weird just weird stuff
uh
but you do have a subconscious and it
does drive things it's not based on the
way you were potty trained which a lot
of this
freud stuff is based on weird um
i think that dude had some issues i mean
some serious issues
you know i need to get daryl cooper on
we need to do a freaking freud breakdown
with daryl cooper and see what's up but
the bottom line is this guy's a cocaine
addict he's a a bit of a quack
um but
some of his
some of his theories were correct and
then on top of that
regardless of where people develop their
personality we all know that people have
personalities
and you know like one of those
personalities is comes direct the word
comes directly from freud which is like
an anal retentive personality we all
know that type of personality it's a
type of personality does it develop from
where someone was how someone was potty
trained no actually that's not where it
develops from it develops from a whole
bunch of different things and a bunch of
different people from a different
different backgrounds can end up with
that type of personality
so he was wrong about where these things
came from but there are certain
personalities that people have
um and
some of these things are reflected
we have to deal with and is someone
that's anal retentive going to be more
apt to look at the military and think to
themselves that looks like my kind of
scene absolutely
is someone that's listening to rock and
roll and their beds not made and their
their root they got a crap on their
floor is that the per type person that's
like i'd really like to join the
military
it's not right it's not
echo charles you weren't like oh man you
know what i'm kind of cruising over here
i'm kind of getting up around the crack
of 10 30 in the morning
maybe the military's my route right
that's funny he said that because i
remember back when my friends were
joining the military
and you know military is always an
option for kind of floating around when
you're young or whatever the one thing
that stood out to me was like having to
wake up at a certain time it's weird
yeah
god check
uh so you got so he starts focusing on
this type of personality um i'm gonna
fast forward through some of the
freudian weirdo crap that he talks about
a little bit he doesn't go he's it's
only a few pages but he says um it does
not need
any vast stretch of the imagination to
see
more than a passing similarity between
these obsessive traits and the practice
of [__] but bull also has a
two-pronged purpose to combat dirt and
prevent illegitimate outbursts of
aggression
aggression that is towards the superiors
um
and potentially dangerous towards parent
figures right
so that's what that's one of the reason
we impose these things is to keep people
in check
at this stage in the argument it is
necessary to issue a caution we are not
saying that military organizations are
hotbeds of obsessional neurosis nor that
those given to [__] are necessarily
manifesting compulsive symptoms on the
contrary all that we have tried to show
is that the anxiety reducing aggression
controlling and tenacious nature of
[__] comes at least partly
explicable so you can you can get it you
can kind of reason with it and it's not
all bad and hey i was freaking
very i mean i was very into you got to
look squared away my boots were always
highly polished my uniform was always
starched even my freaking cami uniform
that's the way i was i you know what's
asking a bruiser
if you here here's an interesting
dichotomy once you left our base our
little compound over there which was
originally called shark base and then
called camp camp mark lee
if you want off that base you were in a
square away uniform when you were on
that base i didn't give a [__] what you
wore you could wear a freaking whatever
flip-flops and a pair of surf shorts i
did not care
so
i wasn't like if you you know i wasn't a
militant i wasn't obsessive about it but
i understood the value of it in certain
situations
um research has shown not only that
psychological arousal is decreased by
ritual but also
that under threatening conditions normal
individuals like compulsive behave like
compulsive neurotics this is when you
see people freaking out a little bit
and they start doing weird you know um
start focusing on some little thing
because they're freaking out about
what's going on around them
since military organizations represent
par excellence outlets for and
consequently defenses against aggression
and disorder they will tend to attract
people who have some difficulty in
reconciling these conflicting needs
people who overvalue aggression order
and obedience no doubt
this conclusion is supported by the
finding that patients suffering from
obsessional neurosis show improvement
during military service so if you've got
a little bit of that activity in your
brain
you're probably going to do pretty good
then he's got this whole flow chart set
up
get the book so you can see it but you
got combat and combat causes a bunch of
uh anxiety death
disorder social disapproval fear of
being called a coward fear of your own
aggressive impulses that's what combat
inflicts on you so how do you deal with
that how do you deal with that well one
way to deal with it is
[__] like chicken [__] like polish
your boots
dogma ritual codes of honor so we put
these codes in place to sort of defend
against all this anxiety
what does that result in rigidity
conformity traditionalism over obedience
aversion to progress and that all those
things attract people with personal
anxieties about dirt aggression
disobedience
right that's where it gets you
and what does that do increases military
incompetence
which by the way then increases the
combat scenarios that you're in which is
a freaking nightmare
if the if if the other thing it does is
it
attracts these people
attracts these people that have you know
that are they care about appearance
promotional prospects disapprove
approval of those uh higher in their
military hierarchy they're scared of
that
so this is just this this
horrible cycle that we end up in
where the anxiety creates this this
freaking [__] and this ritual and
rigidity and conformity
and those things actually create you to
perform worse in combat which means all
those things get worse and you end up in
a horrible cycle
as opposed to someone that's like hey
now's not the time for that we gotta go
fight we that you can actually break out
of this cycle
dude it's so hard to listen to him
explain this even just something as
simple as the word dirt
like
the idea that
and he did it well like you get dirt in
your rifle can you shoot your rifle
that's the problem so we need to be able
to respond to dirt but the response of
oh i want people that don't want dirt so
i'm going to create a scenario by which
it repels the dirt it doesn't allow the
dirt into my system it's actually not
what you want you want somebody goes
yeah
it's going to get dirty here
and and we're not going to react to the
dirt by creating a system that doesn't
let the dirt in we're actually going to
create a system when things get dirty
like no voice we can we can we can deal
with that
not by repelling the dirt but by
accepting the fact that it's going to
get dirty and we're going to clean and
deal with those things but just the way
he paints that picture of that that
cycle of
the psychology of do you want someone
who doesn't like dirt or someone who
does like it to be able to deal with it
and the irony that's inside that is what
it attracts
is the person that can't handle it which
is the thing that's going to get you
killed yes god it's hard to listen to it
is
just just to use these words again so
there's a there's a dichotomy of
leadership right and everything has to
be balanced right
and yet when you think of these words
you think of a military stereotype
rigidity
conformity
traditionalism obedience those are
military characteristics
and they are good right they are good
you've got to be you've got to have some
level of rigidity you've got to want to
conform with what's happening you've got
to be into those traditions you've got
to be obedient those are those are
totally awesome military qualities
and you also got to be able to buck all
of those qualities in order to survive
yeah in order to truly excel
so even these these these
characteristics that he's talking about
you can see that anyone that has those
is going to be attracted to the military
in some level or let's say most people
that have some of those characteristics
are going to be attracted to the
military what the problem comes when you
have
a lot of people like that attracted an
even bigger problem comes is when people
are getting promoted based on those
things and they're not getting promoted
based on creativity they're not getting
promoted based on uh not being a yes man
they're not getting promoted based on
new ideas that's not none of that is
happening
you're getting oh you're more obedient
so you're going to get promoted hey if
you are going into combat do you want to
work for someone that has been promoted
for 19 years because they've been
obedient and rigid and conformed hell no
hell no
and inside the reaction to the dichotomy
you just described is
the less balanced you are with that
reaction the more extreme your reaction
is the worse things are going to be and
if the system reinforces it and the
person goes in that direction
that the inability to react to the
dichotomy by being balanced is yeah
look do we want someone that um you know
will never conform
no you don't want someone that's never
going to perform do we want someone that
just can't obey no we don't want anyone
like that we're not saying that
but man you don't want to go to the
extreme or it's going to suck
all right one last thing before we close
this section out um he says in other
words
this is basically what you and i were
just saying dave in other words those
very characteristics which are demanded
by war
the ability to tolerate uncertainty
spontaneity of thought and action having
an open mind to the receipt of novel and
perhaps threatening information
are the antithesis of those possessed by
people attracted to the controls and
orderliness
of militarism
that's exactly what you and i were just
saying
and um
that statement is important to remember
it's important to remember
you know that
the best qualities for
good performance in war and therefore
good performance in business and life
are the ones that we talk about here all
the time what he just mentioned the
ability to tolerate uncertainty
spontaneity of thought and action having
an open mind
open to new ideas even threatening ideas
having an open mind to threatening ideas
you know how many
discussions i've had where i won in the
initial
conversation in the first four sentences
because when dave came to me and said i
think we should do this a different way
and i said oh sounds like you've thought
this through what do you want to do do
you how many times i've just had a
immediate victory
immediate victory and by victory i mean
all of a sudden dave's not
coming on the offense
he's opening his mind we're going to be
able to come to a positive
net outcome
because when he came to me with i don't
like the way we're doing this
and instead of me saying that's because
you don't understand what's happening
and all of a sudden we're arguing
instead i say oh
really please
please tell me what you think we should
do
oh it's so easy
well how critical is it that you just
when you define the winning is getting
the out the right outcome not winning
the argument i won because i want the
outcome to be right yeah i won because
we figured out the best way to do this
and it wasn't dave's way and it wasn't
my way either we actually compromised
and figured out the best way to make
this happen right freaking ridiculous
those are the qualities we should want
those are qualities we should strive for
so we can be better leaders and
better people
we'll continue this book next time
for now echo speak of getting speaking
of getting better yes
you got the um ways that we can get
better
yeah speaking of which dave
i know you got some stuff to do i do why
don't you kick on out of here man right
on
and with that dave burke had to go
obviously
busy and
well nonetheless we're here we are
trying to
get better
so
what do you got echo charles
uh well
i could go into the whole intelligence
thing but
in the sake of saving time
let's just think of the smart thing to
do on this path that we're on to improve
ourselves we're working out we're
reading
um so through these workouts and trying
to improve ourselves physically and
mentally we might need some help some
supplementation that provides benefits
do we all need help
maybe maybe not
i'm gonna say
i haven't met
people that didn't need
okay
they might not have needed help
but who does not
voluntarily accept some beneficial
benefits
hey we're all going to benefit from
benefits so one of those benefits that
we can have
is from a new energy drink that we have
choco discipline go healthy
not unhealthy so usual legacy energy
drinks they're unhealthy they provide a
good front-end benefit
but they're not healthy back in
detriment this one healthy and tastes
good and gives you energy all upside
you know what else provides like a front
side kind of up
feel good moment
like like the legacy energy drinks
crystal methane
sure i'm just saying yes
the legacy energy drinks think about
what they do
they get they make you feel good for a
very short period of time and then they
kill you
yeah which is what a traditional
legacy
crap
energy drink is going to do
make you feel good for a little bit
and then over time you die yep it's true
whereas
miraculously
miraculously we have made something that
gives you all the upside
of an energy drink meaning you will feel
energized
but later you won't be
coming down with ver multiple diseases
caused by this thing that you put into
your body in fact the opposite is true
you will be more healthy when you get
done drinking one of these than you were
before you drink it think about that
yeah there's no one else that's going to
say that
because they can't
because they didn't go to the degree
that we went to to make sure we were
making something good for you yeah
yeah man yeah it's one of those
no-brainers for sure and it tastes good
a bunch of different flavors
mangoes the best in my opinion not
jacque's opinion but an opinion is one
of these things that you know
my okay my favorite is jocko palmer
which is like the it's like an arnold
palmer sure
i i would not i don't i love it
i love it
and it's number
probably like five or six of the
rankings the sales rankings oh right
like i don't know why people don't love
it so much because arnold palmer is
popular you can go let me put you this
way you can go to a restaurant
tonight and you can order an arnold
palmer because people drink arnold
palmer's and it's a normal flavor for
people to want wait but is that if you
go to a restaurant tonight and get mango
drink the answer is no yeah probably not
so why is that why is why is mango which
it is more popular than jocko palmer
well it depends so wait is arnold palmer
an alcoholic drink no
it's half iced tea straight up
yeah i guess i mean i don't know i mean
it seemed i i have no idea here's the
thing here's there's we've been trying
to figure that i've been trying to
figure that out part of the reason i
think is because i called it jaco palmer
which is like an inside joke that only i
got
i don't think people understand jacquel
palmer is kind of a joke about arnold
palmer oh and we didn't even spell it
like arnold palmer we abbreviate it so i
don't get sued oh yeah right yeah baby
can't be jacking a dude's name and just
putting it on your can no no so we
called it jackal palmer p-o-m-r and it
so we're probably gonna put it we're
gonna we're gonna make it more obvious
as to what it is yeah because like i
said i'm not rolling into a restaurant
tonight with my wife for dinner and
ordering a mango drink of any kind right
but i am ordering
uh uh arnold palmer possibly right but i
guess and not to go too deep into it
what it like it's not like you're gonna
have a discipline go with dinner most of
the time see i'm saying it's like
they're just different contexts of when
you so if i go to the store randomly i
need a snack i might get one of those
little mango smoothies i'd be like oh
dang that's because mango tastes good
you see i'm saying
sure that's like a this is a drink bro
yeah
i'm saying they're all drinks and
they're all drunk drinking on the drink
yeah but yeah i guess no one really
drinks mango juice on a regular basis
but there's no mangoes you want soda
yeah but there's smoothie there's like
ice cream there's like frozen yogurt
there's like mango is a good okay flavor
there's pistachio ice cream too but i'm
not getting a pistachio soda but
pistachio is a good flavor in general
hey and that's that's my whole point
it's under it depends on the context and
what you're you're experiencing the
flavor
i'm saying hey look i like choco palmer
i do i like mango better
of course
but either way it doesn't matter because
each person's opinion is individualized
to them doesn't matter you could like
taco bomb or level literally level 10
like the it cannot get any better it has
no bearing on my influence or my opinion
on what i like well that's where i'm at
level 10 and if you want to get some get
some yep so yeah the again different
flavors
get the one you want try them all that's
what i would say because the mango seems
more risky because it's exotic
orange not so much seems to say true so
you might be like oh that's a safe one
you know yeah but hey man with great
risks come great rewards as a wise man
once said possibly also on this path you
want to look up after your joints and
immunity joint warfare super krill oil
vitamin d3 cold war these are all
immunity and joint protective
supplements don't forget about the monk
don't forget about the mulk which is a
dessert
it's a dessert that is also good for you
again there's not too many desserts that
you can eat you can relish the flavor
and
the texture
and the whole thing from a from a
like a taste perspective but there's
more than that the whole thing the whole
consumption
you can relish
and when you get done you're stronger
you're better the whole experience the
whole experience yeah it's not like when
you go down the freaking you go down to
uh
to the local ice cream store and you
order a mint chocolate chip milkshake
and they make it right and it's good
yeah get a good experience we're not mad
at that and then you get done
you know what just happened yeah yeah
you poisoned yourself yeah that's what
happened you pay a bit of a price you're
paying a big price and you for sure
can't do it again the next day and the
next and the next day oh you definitely
can't do that don't do that yeah don't
do don't do that because there's
something called
type 2 diabetes which you're working on
it's true you're in route yeah you're in
route oh yeah if that's what we're doing
what's the if that's what we're doing
every day it's true all kinds of heart
disease you got problems yeah don't do
that
yeah so you kind of got to stay away
from that one play this weird balancing
like game there's no reason to balance
right you have to you can go you can get
mulk you can get done
with your dinner you have that sweet
tooth which is fine normal
but you can
follow that sweet tooth right to the
mulk container
and you're gonna play any you don't have
to play any balancing game you just go
yeah as much monk as you want much more
straight up
you want five scoops of milk
good gonna be thick oh it's gonna be
thick unless you add some more milk are
you going foot i've scooped some more
the most out of your honest three scoops
yeah three is my max five five would be
guys you're going hard but you know if
they're if you're there bro up to you
yeah get it you call it get it man get
it five squeeze out that's 100 grams of
protein yeah 100 something yeah hey you
get all this stuff at jackalfuel.com and
if you want to get free shipping which
look the reason
this isn't uh hey order now and get free
shipping that's not what we're doing
here's what we're doing we're competing
with
one of the biggest companies in the
world
who offers you free shipping cool they
got a big log uh algorithm that's
figuring this stuff out and they got all
this mass scale and all this things
going on they're trying to get your
information they're trying to get you
into the zone
where they can own you which is
understandable yeah we get it
we want you to have an option to still
get free shipping and not enter the
matrix
yeah so you go to jugglefield.com stay
out the matrix oh yeah and and if you
subscribe to one of these items which
you should because then you'll be able
to get it with free shipping there you
go jockofield.com you can also get the
getting at the vitamin shop
you can get the drinks the energy drinks
at wawa on the east coast we're working
on some other convenience stores right
now sorry west coast
that the convenience terrain
a little bit rough
a little bit rough the way it's split up
and what's where so we're working it but
if you've got a vitamin shop near you
or where you are live work whatever and
grab it from there oh for sure all good
100 100
yeah there you go check it out yeah it's
good also
jiu jitsu we're doing jiu jitsu to know
jiu jitsu or to not know jujitsu which
one is more beneficial
do we want to know jiu-jitsu yes sir we
do i don't i don't care if you know one
day of jiu-jitsu it's better than zero
days of jiu-jitsu anyway when you do
jiu-jitsu you're gonna need a ghee
yep hey i can only train jiu-jitsu one
day a week
so i'm not gonna train is not the answer
yeah it's true the answer is i can only
trained you to do once a month so i'm
doing it once a month that's the answer
yes there it is you get the chance of
training did you do training just that's
what we're doing it's true so when you
get your ghee you get the best ghee that
you possibly can made in america by the
way in origin geek go to origin usa.com
for these things you get rash guards on
there as well some hoodies on there also
from origin usa american-made denim
jeans
i got my delta 68 jeans yeah my favorite
jeans yeah of all time by the way yeah
and fyi leaf hit me up too because he
got his you got a pair of delta 68s and
we re-cut the delta 68 it's probably
like
i don't know
six months ago or something like that
and
to provide more comfort
i dig it yeah so
delta 68's the best most comfortable
things that you can put on your legs and
they look good too by the way so here
and you know maybe you care about this
maybe you don't but here's the thing
factually this is what happened so put
mine on i had an event to go to called
the muster might have heard of it wore
the delta 68 origin genes to the muster
they're pretty new too
and wear a white t-shirt
my wife likes me and a white t-shirt
don't ask why it's just how it is let's
just know that these are all things i do
not care about yes but the concept the
underlying concept i think most of us
it has some value
so she was like
hey you're looking really nice
boom
that's all you got to know delta 68. hey
functional made in america look good um
you know durable all this stuff get
these jeans and echo charles's wife will
think you look good no she'll probably
won't look at you at all oh hopefully i
won't look at you but she thinks i look
good so maybe if you're married or have
a girlfriend or boyfriend or whatever
they'll think you look good in them too
they look good we got work wear coming
out by the way if you don't know that we
got work work coming out so you when
you're out there on the construction
site you're out there as a lineman
you're out there being on the farm
whatever you're doing you're working we
have work we're coming which is made in
america
yeah
but for real me for real made in america
every ounce of that thing every rivet
every every thread made in america even
the threat itself made in america we're
making work where for workers
for american workers made by american
workers
that's what we're doing yes sir origin
usa.com
also
if you want to get a shirt
or a hat or hoodie that says discipline
equals freedom or you want to represent
this path in any way
go to jackostore.com that's where you
can get this stuff
some good stuff on there some new stuff
on there
oh jiu jitsu
section you know um where look if you do
jiu jitsu and you kind of want to
represent the path
and jiu jitsu kind of a hybrid
representation scenario you can do that
now you know what's cool i noticed at
the muster
we have a jiu jitsu night the second
night we do jiu jitsu introduction to
jiu jitsu and
there's more people now
there used to be almost no one did
jiu-jitsu yeah and now
majority of people have done jiu-jitsu
so we're getting in the right direction
yeah we want everyone to do jiu-jitsu
we could keep it a secret right right
that's a kind of an ego thing right if i
don't tell anyone about this yeah i'm
just gonna be the baddest man on the
block just so much more superior i'm so
much more superior that's a
that's a dork move
it's
dorky yeah because actually no you know
what i don't think that's that's not
called the door that's an ego move yeah
that's just pure you go i'm gonna blame
you i'm not gonna teach you anything
yeah i'm i'm just gonna keep this
special thing this super power to myself
yeah
it's kind of surprising that the gracies
i think the gracies
did it right because i think
that as they broke it out
then they started promoting it
and teaching it and spreading the word
i think if they would have failed to do
that
they would have been five years behind
it would have taken an extra five years
for people to start kind of figuring out
on their own
just from videos and ufc and all those
things
but
it just would have been bad they did the
right thing when it was time to bring it
out they brought it out and started
teaching its people well actually i'll
kind of in a way do you want better
probably not even five years when you
think about it
because you said because the because you
just said they they they might figure it
out because of videos in ufc or whatever
the whole existence of usc is because of
horizontal traces so they wouldn't have
had the ufc
ufc straight up wouldn't exist because
that's all it was essentially
demonstration demonstration of how
effective jiu-jitsu is in a real fight
that's essentially what ufc one was so
bad that wouldn't exist no one would do
it it'd be probably relegated to little
secret sex
like brazil little
secret dojos doing their secret art just
rolling everything so it's there it's
there for everyone to get into yep it's
not like that and if you want to get a
t-shirt that talks you know
representation
shows that you're on the jiu jitsu path
oh yeah
yeah bunch of stuff on there we have a
subscription situation as well called
the shirt locker there's a new creative
i was at the monster you might have
heard of it
um and every once well well let's face
it every day i was wearing a different
shirt from the shirt locker
every single shirt that i wore someone
asked hey where did you get that shirt
including people who weren't even there
for the muster
like where'd you get that shirt the
support sog
that was a good one a lot of people
asked about that one it's a good one
um nonetheless good shirts on there so
yeah you get a new shirt every month
creative designs kind of new
new designs creative outside of the box
designs but relative
and very awesome good feedback on that
one yeah also if you're going to
subscribe to things you might as well
subscribe to this podcast right here
leave a review and all that stuff
also we have a couple other podcasts we
have jocko unraveling with myself and
daryl cooper dc we have the grounded
podcast we have the warrior kid podcast
we have
the jocko underground
jockowunderground.com where we have an
alternate universe
where in the event of
tyrannical
activities in this country
and no one knows what to do
we'll be able to tell you what to do
we'll be there we'll be on the
underground jock underground.com we made
it so we'd have an alternate platform in
case something happens with this
platform
and
because we did that
it cost money to do that and if you want
to support that it cost you eight eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month and
in order to give you something back for
that in the immediate we do another
little podcast on there we talk about
some we do some q a we talk about some
alternate
things so if you want to subscribe to
that do it we appreciate it also if you
can't afford it we understand
things are tough out there right now if
you can't afford that eight dollars and
eighteen cents a month
just email assistance jocko
underground.com and we will take care of
you and we also have a youtube channel
where we make videos
um i'm sort of the brains behind them
and i'm sort of the person that thinks
of the ideas and then echo is the
technical guy that does the follows the
mechanics of making them sure if you
want to subscribe to that yes sir you
can do that oh yeah that bothers you bro
no no no no
it so bothers you
yeah actually more than it bothers me
you're just really really happy about it
that's more than the contrast you know
yeah you take this video stuff really
not bro you know it's just it's just a
thing you know it's just a thing i
didn't realize how much of a world the
video thing is like there's some what do
you mean i mean it's like uh it has its
own little thing right its own little
its own little ecosystem what you're in
oh like the industry or whatever the
circles yeah whatever yeah yeah there
you kind of size each other up and so
i don't know if i size people up but i
don't know you size up their cameras oh
yes i definitely say yeah you size up
their videos
yeah i mean they create a field like
are you trying to act like you you you
don't i'll be i might say something like
oh yeah i saw this video it looked
pretty cool you're like oh i sent it to
you
and you'll be like
um
you know
i don't know what their aspect ratio was
or whatever i'm like okay bro
frame rate is all off
uh hey look you might be right i don't
know if you want to check out echo
charles's expert video production
then you can check out our youtube
channel sure jacko podcast
hey origin has a cool one too origin usa
if you want to see what's going on up
there
you can check that out
also psychological warfare if you want
to hear
no no not if you want to hear
if you're struggling
to get past the moment of weakness and
you need to hear
someone with integrity
named jocko tell you why
hey this moment of weakness is fleeting
and it's insignificant if you want to
hear that in whatever way psychological
warfare oh get down it's an album the
tracks of him helping you pass these
moments
you suck we all have them don't forget
about flipsidecanvas.com where dakota
meyer is selling cool stuff to hang on
your wall that's also made in america
got a bunch of books new book coming out
called final spin you better order it
now if you want that first to dish look
that's what you got to do
to support there's
what's the publisher thinking they're
thinking well you know jacob you're
really not a novelist you've written
some you've written some non-fiction but
you know you're not really a novelist
i don't know
we we shouldn't really make too many of
these well then the first reviews came
in and they were like damn good yeah
so anyways if you want to check that out
if you want to order that first dish if
you want to support the cause you want
other people to get this
message check out final spin
it's available now for pre-order it'll
be it'll be to you
uh in a week by the way
it's coming out november 9th so check
that out leadership strategy and tactics
field manual the code the evaluations of
protocol this one equals freedom field
manual way the warrior get one two three
four so many people at the muster came
up and said thanks for running that book
miking the dragon same thing if you've
got kids or you know kids get them get
the freaking kids those books
get to get get the kids that you know
actually one jiu jitsu guy he's uh
instructor black belch he said he just
carries the warrior kid in his back
yeah he meets a kid he's like here you
go
here you go
can you imagine the impact that's gonna
have if i would have got that book i
would be i would be ruler of the world
right now yeah and a benevolent ruler of
the world be nice sure i wouldn't be a
bully i'd be a warrior kid
so get warrior kid
for your kids for all kids about face by
hackworth and then of course extreme
ownership and the dicardium dichotomy of
leadership that i wrote with my brother
life babin
also echelon front speaking of late fab
and we have a leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership no
matter what's going on in your company
you think you got issues you think you
got problems things are going wrong
things are going sideways guess what
leadership is the solution go to
echelonfront.com to see how we can help
you solve your problems whether it's us
coming directly to you to consult
whether it's you coming to the muster
whether it's our field training
exercises ef battlefield we've got all
kinds of things that we do to help you
get through your situations utilizing
leadership and that includes we have an
online training program an online
leadership training program
extreme ownership academy this is where
you can learn to lead and you can stay
ahead of the game and you can practice
and you can rehearse and you can take
courses and you can come on live and ask
me questions you don't learn leadership
in one day it doesn't work
you need to constantly train just like
you go to the gym
just like you do jiu jitsu
extreme ownership.com if you want to
check that out and if you want to help
service members
active and retired
service members if you want to help the
families if you want to help gold star
families you can check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved go to
americasmightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my p-brained
pontifications
or you need more of echo's ridiculous
ramblings or dave's
enthusiastic extras you can find us on
the interwebs on twitter on the gram and
on that face
dave is that david r burke echo zadek
with charles and i am at jacqueline
willing and thanks to everyone out there
worldwide in the military standing the
watch to keep us safe thank you also
thanks to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for standing the watch here on
the home front to keep us safe and to
everyone else out there
keep an open mind
free your mind
don't think you have to control
everything because you can't
you're not going to be able to put
everything in perfect order that is not
possible instead be ready to shift be
ready to change be ready to adapt be
ready to adjust to new environments and
new information
don't let your mind get stuck
don't let it get
trapped
instead free your mind
free
your
mind
and until next time
this is echo and jocko
out